why would a distributor become a
filmmaker isn't there more money
in film distribution than there is in
making movies that's a great question
and a lot of my distribution associates
thought i was nuts when i went that
direction
but filmmaking is about the making of
movies
you know the distribution is is is a
business
and it's it could be a very lucrative
business and and fun and i enjoyed it a
lot
but my heart was always i went into the
film business
to make movies and i started in
distribution
in some ways by accident because i went
to get a
production job and the only job they had
available in the company that i got
hired into was a sales job in the
distribution department
so i figured to get my foot in the door
i would take that job
in the hopes of moving over into the
production department i mean that lasted
22 years
and in hindsight i learned a ton and and
it was super valuable so that i could
you know
be successful in making my own movies
and distributing them but
that was only in hindsight if somebody
had come into my office you know six
months into my distribution job and said
hey we have an opening in production i
would have taken it
immediately because my heart always was
in making independent movies so
the truth is i think the attraction
to the film business is making the
movies but you had gone to law school
you were practicing law or you just had
your jd
and you'd come from canada yeah so
here's how that happened
so when i was in my last year of high
school my father said to me
he said what do you think you want to do
in your life and i
said i want to make movies and he said
do you want to produce
or direct and i said i don't know what's
the difference
and he said well producing is all about
business so if you want to produce you
should either get a law degree or a
business degree
and if you want to direct you should go
to film school because it's all about
art and you should get a you know film
degree
and i said yeah producing sounds kind of
cool so
so i went i did an undergrad in finance
and commerce and i
and then i went to law school in with
the 100
idea and direction that i was going
going to into the film business to
produce
that was the reason i went to law school
i never had any intentions of practicing
law unless it was for a studio or
something related to film ah so your
goal was not to
do litigation and you know never i went
to film school
with the intention of producing movies
because it's a super you know valuable
skill to have
and now now that i've produced seven
movies i understand how valuable it is
i mean in law school i didn't really
realize how much contract work there is
you know how much ip work and that type
of thing that there is in making
any movie or any any type of
entertainment content
so it's a great skill to have like legal
skills and and finance
financial skills are great also what i
didn't say is that in hindsight
if my father knew that i was actually
going to go into the film business and
not become a practicing lawyer he might
have given me some different advice
it worked out fine when i was in law
school
i spent a lot of time writing
screenplays
as opposed to studying for legal exams
and i wasn't the best law student
but i was super happy and i it gave me a
release and actually produced two plays
like musicals with a friend of mine who
was
in a different division and he was a
musician and we wrote and produced two
plays which we staged
so i got to be very creative during law
school
and i think it got me through law school
were the screenplays that you wrote
based on a
you know mock trials or you know so this
is
this is sort of a leading question and
it's going to go in a different
direction
the reason i wanted to get into the film
business one i love movies
but two like most filmmakers i have that
one
pet project that i had to do in my life
and
it was luckily i actually got to make it
so it was the first film that i made and
it's called my brother's keeper
and my grandfather when we were growing
up um used to sit me and my brothers on
his knee and tell us a story
about um two brothers who had to help
each other
my grandfather you know was from europe
and he big on family and all this type
of stuff so
he probably fabricated the story we
never knew if it was real or not
in hindsight i think it was a
fabrication but it was a great story
and he would tell it to us every sunday
we would go and sit with him and
and he would tell us and then he used to
pay us 25 cents to tell him the story
back
so all of his grandchildren do the story
inside and out because it was his legacy
and i wan i decided that i wanted to
make a movie of that story
and so that is why i really really
wanted to get in the film business to
make that particular movie
and so when i was in law school i wrote
the script to that movie
and when i graduated from law school
i used that script to send it around to
all these production companies to say
hey either one
would you like to make this movie or two
you know do you have a job
and here's what i can do i'm a writer
blah blah blah you know
and i got no response like most people
do
you know i'm sure nobody read the script
or whatever and that was you know an
awakening
which most indie filmmakers get um
i mean it opened the door to say one
company said hey
we see you have a law degree we don't
have a job in production but you might
be useful to us and you know in
distribution on the sales side so i took
that job
and but i always dreamed of making that
movie
and that that was my direction and my
goal in life
and i left distribution to make that
movie to become
that was my first movie it's called my
brother's keeper i released it 14 years
ago
and it was sorry in 2004 yeah
so 16 years ago now and um it's it's
still
it's my dream i got to live my dream
which
is a wonderful thing in life in in
anything you do
but i'm a lucky guy one that i had a
dream and two that i actually got to
live it
and that movie every time i watch it it
brings back that feeling of who i was
and what i wanted to do
and um like i said it's it's a legacy
for me because
and it ends with you know a tribute to
my grandfather saying based on a story
that my grandfather told us
and i twisted it around a little i took
the story of the themes and i twisted
around
with two different characters two
brothers and i gave it a little bit of a
twist
and but i i love it and the brothers are
twins
identical twins
so the brothers are identical twins and
in his story the brother
the brothers weren't identical twins but
i happened to be an identical twin
so i thought that would be a really
unique twist so that's the twist i gave
to it but the story wasn't originally
like that
so um i made it into that because also
the relationship between identical twins
is
super super unique and very tight and
being an identical twin i understood it
implicitly
i didn't i wrote the movie and i
produced it but i didn't direct it
because
i didn't really have any filmmaking
skills you know i had a lot of business
skills but not filmmaking
but i did hire a director who was an
identical twin
because i wanted him to capture those
sensitivities which he did
well i bet that was was that difficult
to find um
not as difficult as you might think um
especially i was living in toronto at
the time and toronto is a big film hub
and there's a lot of people in the
industry
so i put the word out and uh there were
quite a few
i'm not quite a few maybe you know five
or six who
identical twins who were so-called
directors
you know like this guy hadn't made a
feature before he made some
shorts and some tv commercials but never
a feature so this was his first feature
we were all a little bit green but it
worked out
did you actually quit a job to make it
so i had i started off
i had worked primarily for big companies
there's no studios per se
in canada there's some big media
companies but nothing like you know the
five major studios here the six majors
here so i worked for a very large
public media company for most of my
career
i switched around between two of them
and then
i left that media company to start my
own company but it was a distribution
company
because i also have a very
entrepreneurial side to me
so i felt that i had learned the
business and i left and started my own
company
and so i had access to know-how in
distribution
and then about four to five years into
owning and operating that
company that's when i said i'm ready to
make my this movie
so i still had my own operation but i
switched gears
um i had a lot of people in the
distribution side who were
competent i still own the company but
but i switched gears and i went into the
artistic side
content side and be that's what i did
full time
and that's when everybody said are you
nuts i said like you have the greatest
thing going you have a great lifestyle
you have a successful business
why are you doing this and i said
because i also have a dream
and a dream surpasses everything
you know i think someone had that same
conversation with jeff bezos
when he when he said he wanted to pick
up and move
from wherever new york city to he wasn't
even sure yet i think at the time he and
his wife
and then they they he had like this long
walk with someone if i remember the
chapter in the book correctly and they
said what are you doing
so sometimes these these different
things you know they
they they seem crazy to the outside
world whether it was
in hindsight worth it but sometimes
people just have to do things
it wasn't a financially um you know
it wasn't the best financial move but it
was by far the best
psychological emotional and comforting
move in my life by far
i am i i honestly i consider myself so
lucky
to be able to be in a position where i
could green light my own movie though
and make it the way i wanted to make it
a feature i mean
who gets that opportunity not too many
people
so i'm very fortunate that way and it
had an emotional component because it
was a story
that was very close to your heart and
absolutely absolutely
after i made that movie i felt
totally fulfilled i felt like i had
gotten to where i wanted to go
um in my life certainly in my career and
then the rest was
it's it's very comforting to
have a goal and to accomplish it and to
achieve it now
it didn't you know wasn't a financially
huge success
it made it made some money because i was
in distribution so i knew how to
i knew how to monetize it but i would
have made it anyways even if it wasn't
monetizable i
i had to make that movie that was that
was a must for me
jeff you say making a movie is like
starting a new business
why make that comparison making an
independent movie
um there's so much to it i mean there's
so many components to making a movie
think of
you're creating something um from
scratch
from an idea so and that's what a
business is you have an idea and you
want to bring it to life and bring
whatever it is your product or service
to market and you have to go through all
those steps
and components in order to do that i
mean that's what making a movie is
ultimately you're going to develop it
produce it mar and then market it
and so that's what a business is it's
creating like a product or service
and then putting it out to market and
hoping that consumers
consume it and in case of a movie it's
the consumption is watching it
or buying it you know whatever in that
case um so
how is that any different than any
business that's what all businesses do
they create from an idea a product or
service and put it out to market to be
consumed
and that's why i relate it to a business
now in
in the studios there's two types of
i believe that the studio business and
the independent business are actually
two separate businesses the way
a public company would be different than
an entrepreneurial company
so let's deal with the public company so
a public company has shareholders and
they have a responsibility and a mandate
to earn revenue for you know and
dividends or whatever for their
shareholders
that's their mission their mission is to
create wealth so that they can
distribute it to their shareholders
so everybody's focused on that on wealth
creation and
you know and whatever it takes to be
profitable
that's why corporations exist especially
public corporations
in the case of a so that's what a studio
is
i mean every studio is a public company
so every studio
has to be financially successful for two
reasons one if they're not
they can't exist and make the products
they want to do and two is their
shareholders wouldn't support it
so the studios are public companies and
they are financial institutions that
create wealth
that's the way i look at them they
happen to be the product they happen to
be making is you know entertainment
movies tv shows whatever
but it's for the reason of generating
profit
there's not many studio people i've met
who will say to you
i want to do this because this is what i
like and enjoy and it doesn't matter if
we make profit
they won't last too long in the studio
system they have to be profit oriented
on the entrepreneurial side which is
what i would relate to the indie
filmmaking business
you also if you want to exist and
continue you
you do have to make a profit like any
business
but you can take more risks the stakes
are not lower and you're not
you're not accountable to anybody other
than yourself and your investors
on the public company side you're
accountable to all your shareholders
here the accountability factor is less
so
you don't want to blow your brains out
and lose all your investors money or
whoever it is it might just be your own
money in your own time
but you're you have the ability to take
more risks which is what an entrepreneur
does
maybe have a little bit more fun maybe
go
a little bit more passion do the things
that you truly want to do
like when i speak to filmmakers the two
questions they always ask me is
what genre film should i make that would
be most saleable
and that's question number and i answer
that question and i say
great question but let me ask you a
question before i answer your question
what genre film do you like to make see
in a studio you'd never have that
discussion
that would be we need to make here's
what's trending here's what's happening
in the marketplace here's what we're
forecasting
this is where we're going to make the
most amount of money in the entrance
nobody says hey
what do you think we should do what
would be the most fun what would be like
the most artistic
in the entrepreneurial world you can
have that conversation art actually
matters
i mean you know listen in the studio
world you have to make good product
it has to be fantastic and very artistic
in order for people to be entertained by
it
but they don't have the luxury of
picking and choosing the way an
entrepreneur does
because they're again they're
accountable to a smaller group of people
so but on the business side why related
to a business is because
when you decide to make a movie from
start to finish um if you want to be
a what i call a career filmmaker who
makes just more than one movie
it would be helpful if you were
profitable because that way
one you'd have enough money you'd make
your money back which would help to make
your next movie
two that would evoke investor confidence
if you are
dealing with investors they would say
hey this guy's you know able to make
money
with the stuff we're investing in so so
it does make it a lot easier
if you're profitable on the
entrepreneurial side
but you don't have to necessarily be
profitable because i mean
it might not lead to a good career um
but you could be what you know a hobby
filmmaker just an artist who says
i have a statement that i want to make
to the world and i'm going to do it
through a movie
and it's important for me this is this
is the kind of movie i want to make this
is
the artistic integrity that i i don't
really want to compromise so i'm not
really worried about what the audience
thinks i'm more worried about what i
think
i personally don't think that makes for
necessarily great business practice
because it might not generate the profit
that you're looking for
but an entrepreneur gets to do that
that's part of being in business
and you know if you look at the
statistics of entrepreneurs
most small businesses fail miserably
it's really really tough to navigate
opening a new business
that would be the same with indie films
the good news about making any film is
even though you didn't make any money
and
you could say it sort of failed
financially it didn't necessarily fail
artistically
so you left you're going to leave the
world with your legacy and your message
and whatever
and hopefully audiences will enjoy it
maybe they didn't pay for it but
hopefully they'll enjoy it so at least
you get
that out of it whereas a failed business
on the entrepreneurial side you know
let's say open a restaurant or a
clothing store or something like that
and fails i mean you're just left with a
lot of debt and a lot of aggravation
right that's that was actually i was
going to bring up the next thing is is
certain businesses of course
and i was wondering if we could make
that comparison to certain types of
movies so if you have
a a restaurant which what is it 90
failure rate i'm not sure if that that's
the right percentage
but then versus say someone selling
widgets and it's it's
led lights and it's all the rage
are certain movies in a category of the
restaurant and certain
movies are in the category of the
widgets i would look at it a little
differently
um because you know certain restaurants
in certain locations i think have a
better chance than
other restaurants in other locations so
so i would say
certain there's a trend in the movie
business you know
as you know like sometimes horror movies
are the hot rage sometimes it's sci-fi
um i and there's you definitely if
you're
in it to make money if you're in the
film business to make money
you definitely have to consider what
your audience wants to see
and who your audience actually is and
that was the second question like i
always
said they say you know what what film
should i make
and the second question is actually how
do i get it to the audience
so the first way to get a film to an
audience is to identify who the audience
is
which means you have to choose the genre
of film that
you are going to aim at your audience so
for example i
tend to make family films i like family
films i enjoy making them
i enjoy the genre i work kids they were
growing up
it was a nice thing for me to do but i
did it because i really enjoy family
films
so and then within family films i'm very
specific my films are very specific
they're generally sports dramas based
on true stories because i love that
genre
and it's very very marketable
especially each one has a definition a
defined market
so like i've made two gymnastics films
so i can go to the gymnastics
world and i'm able to actually target
market
gymnasts and dancers so i don't have to
go generically across the whole
gambit to try to market to everybody i
can specifically hone my marketing
efforts in
on you know gymnasts and dancers who i
would think would be engaged by the
movie
by these particular movies which has
worked
so as a business decision it does help
to
to identify the audience that you want
to go to and then you know choose the
movie that hopefully will cater to that
audience or vice versa if you're going
to choose a movie
make sure you identify how you're going
to who the audience is and how you're
going to market to them before you make
the movie
otherwise you it's hard to do it after
the fact
you got to have i mean this is what
studios do i mean i'm convinced i've
never worked at a studio but i'm 100
convinced that if the marketing
department doesn't greenlight the movie
then the production
department's not making it they need to
know who it's going to how it's going to
get marketed what the plan is going to
be
in order to monetize you know the
product they make
and indie film producers generally don't
do that but if they did do that then
it kind of like a restaurant or opening
a restaurant
like if you're going to open say an
indian restaurant
in an asian marketplace
it could be it could be tricky i don't
know maybe
asian people like indian food but you
better do your research and make sure
they do
otherwise your restaurant could be
fantastic it just might be in the wrong
place
and that's the same with the film like
you know if you're gonna
make a film that caters to a certain
audience and you haven't really
identified who the audience is or how to
get to them
you can make the greatest film of all
time but it's going to be hard to get it
to your audience
you know and you had mentioned earlier
and i love this point that you're making
about clothing and it brings back uh uh
something i watched about diane von
furstenberg and her wrap dress
which was all the rage i think it was
late 70s 80s
and then i think she got in trouble
because she went and bought a new
inventory
and it was so popular but taste had
changed if i remember correctly so she
had all this inventory
that was not selling at the time i think
it made a resurgence later
but do audiences that's the thing if we
know the rage is
horror movies with a certain soundtrack
and different things
can the audience change and now you've
got this
this excess surplus i have a
maybe a bit of a skewed opinion about
that so
i believe that anything that is unique
good and really entertaining will can
actually create a trend itself
and can find an audience and
you know it's funny i notice over the
years especially with studio pictures
that's always with studio movies um
trends seem to develop like
you know you know in the 70s you had the
star wars star
trek all these star you know space
themes right
like that doesn't just come out of
nowhere so i've always thought about
like
how does a trend like that develop do
people
like audience members or you know
consumers write into studios and say hey
we want to see star movies like they
don't
here's how i think it develops i think
that that creative people
develop these stories and then they go
pitch them to studio execs
and um you know in the case of again i
just read about lucas and star wars so i
don't know for sure i've never met lucas
i've never interviewed him but but
it's you know he he says in his book
that he went to everybody
he knocked on every single door many
times and got rejected with star wars
um but every time because i worked in
big media companies but every time
a filmmaker walks out the door after
they've pitched a crazy unique concept
they leave and then and the executives
in the room say
yeah it was crazy but but what if like
you know like at warner brothers they
say what if paramount
takes it and we're wrong like what about
this so you notice that like when one
movie comes out
five movies come out and i think it's
because nobody wants to be wrong
so they have to cover themselves and
make sure they have something else to
offer
because while all of a sudden the five
star movies the star wars movies or
related type of stuff come out why all
of a sudden is there a
a run on horror movies or run on
westerns
or romantic comedies or stuff like that
there's generally a run on them
and generally you know i mean the movie
business is driven by the studios and
the big movies the theatrical movies
and i think there's a run on them
because every studio doesn't want to be
wrong so they have to hedge their bets
to make sure that whoever
green lit whatever they did and they
didn't greenlight it they have something
to cover
that's my theory okay it's a conspiracy
theory that's what i believe to be true
because it's just too random that
everybody would be looking at the same
stuff at the same time
randomly so i feel like that's how it
happens
now there are genres that are evergreen
i personally think family is an
evergreen genre that's one of the
reasons i work in it
because as long as there's families as
long as there's kids that grow up and
want to their parents want to view
movies together there needs to be family
movies so i believe that's
evergreen most genres are evergreen
just some are trending more than others
but
the way the way that clothing trends and
cars trend and that type of thing
i believe it's all based on marketing
and i believe the studios
sort of decide what the audience is
going to see
and when they're going to see it it's
not the audiences who demand something
the studios say
we're going to now move it into this
genre we're going to release
10 horror films we're going to release
10 rom-coms or whatever
and that's what we're doing because
i'm not sure why that's what we're doing
and which makes
a trend develop or die it's a great
point like
found footage so blair witch and it
seemed like it
it tipped off other found footage films
and it became all the rage after a while
it did but you know in order for a trend
to develop
it's not necessarily only part of it is
what people are making
it's primarily what is being released by
studios
so there could be you know ten of those
kind of blair witch style movies
um the first one happened to be
successful so they might as well
run a few more and see how that goes but
if
if the second and third are not
successful you can be sure that's going
to die very quickly as quickly as it
started
so the trends really go with the profit
like they put them out they see what
happens if it makes profit then they go
with more and more
until they exhaust it and then they have
to come with something else
it's kind of like fashion i think
does a movie start with an idea or does
it start with an audience
depends who you ask um
i would say an idea and then the
and then you would gauge whether there's
an audience for that idea
um but if you do have an audience
and you want to cater to that audience
and there's demand
then you create an idea to cater to it
not unlike a product
right let's say that
then again let's use apple as an example
okay
you know the founders of apple said hey
the computer market is new and we need
something that's super user friendly
that's what the audience the consumers
want they want
super super friendly so then they create
i think then they create a product to
cater to that demand as opposed to hey
we're going to make a super
well might i guess it could go either
way we're going to make a super friendly
user-friendly computer and we suspect
that the
consuming base will really love it
so it i guess they could go either way
whereas you know with the
case of a movie generally independent
films start with an idea
um because independent filmmakers are
artists and they want to express their
artistic
you know sensitivities and that type of
thing so they'll say this is what i want
to do
and i'll make a movie to do it and
unfortunately not enough of them think
about
who the audience is going to be
afterwards and then it's really hard to
get to that audience
i would think studios though would say
hey feels like
like we talked about before there's some
trending going on in you know horror
films or sci-fi's and
so let's let's get some sci-fi ideas in
here let's make a couple more of those
because it feels like that's the way the
market's going to go for a bit
and then when the idea has
brought such an audience hence sequels
happen
and then it almost seems like the
original idea
gets cheapened in a sense toward the end
of the sequel run
maybe i'm wrong how does that happen how
does this precious idea
that garnered this audience then through
many
iterations become it's like okay i think
they
they they i don't want to say beat a
dead horse but you know and that and
that they
they took too long with it or there's
too many they tried too hard
and it ruined that original concept
maybe not sqls are
are you know a component of marketing i
mean when something works
why not capitalize on it and make some
more money off of it
so hence a sequel that's what it is i
mean
you know you have a product that is
working really well
bring out the second edition of it you
know iphone worked well bring out iphone
two bring out iphone three bring out
iphone four
why not you got the market they want
more better greater
just keep giving it to them in the case
of a sequel
in movies um you use the word cheapen
i could give you lots of examples where
the sequel is actually better than the
original one
and i would say that you know empire
strikes back with star wars was a better
movie than star wars
it needed star wars to get it going but
that was a far more entertaining movie
and that's because now the concept was
proven and
studio was prepared to spend more money
and maybe give a little more creative
control to the producers and directors
and that type of thing so hence they
had more resources to make a better
movie but you are right in a lot of
cases
it becomes cheaper because they're just
trying to capitalize on you know a trend
that they built and it just throw it out
there
similar style and and not really think
about it as much and it's not
as artistic but the bottom line is they
work
i mean statistically if you look at the
numbers and the economics behind it
sequels generate a lot of money and and
you know
maybe not as much as the first one maybe
sometimes more
i mean look at the rocky franchise um
they just kept being bigger and bigger
and bigger
those movies so why not
it's the same story you tell it over a
few times but it's a good story
and people like it so if you get people
invested in the characters and the idea
and you take them on that ride and it
works sometimes then
it's not always about it doesn't always
cheapen it it's about the audience i
mean if you're focused on the audience
and
the audience is enjoying it and that's
what they want then i wouldn't use the
word cheap in it
it's you're just giving them more of
what they want artistically you know if
you're talking about an artist an artist
might say
you've compromised your artistic
integrity by you know just copying the
same thing over and over and over and
that would be correct but for the
studios it's primarily about
profit so why not get more of the same
they're predictable and do you think
that studios bank on the fact that the
audience will age
and they can go along with these sequels
or they know that they're going to be
new audiences cropping up
the the descendants of the original
audience well i mean it's funny i just
mentioned rocky because that's a perfect
example of what you're talking about
because they they that thing was the
five rocky movies
and then you know years later they come
up with creed
and creed is you know apollo creed the
character from the first movie his son
now they have a whole new line of movies
based on that
so would you call that a sequel or what
would that be
it's an ancillary product that came out
of a very successful franchise
and so they're creating a second
franchise out of our first franchise
which i think is super smart
and you know like so we grew up with
rocky
right um i don't enjoy the creed movies
as much as the rocky movies but my kids
do
my kids like them way better because
that's the new hero
you know the he's younger he's
got a certain personality that they
relate to more than you know than rocky
sure times change yeah so do i
necessarily does it cater to me no but
but
it caters to a younger audience that you
know sort of capitalizes on
the same thing that they capitalize on
us with rocky
sure and it works well
what do you think about the sentence
don't write for the market
i'm not a typical filmmaker i come from
the business side of the filmmaking
industry like
i told you i didn't go to film school i
went to
business school and law school so um and
i wouldn't
i'm not going to say that i'm not
artistic because i am and i really
really care about the creative process
and the artistic integrity that
very very much so because you don't want
to cheapen the product
i take a lot of pride in the stuff that
i do
but don't write for the audience like
who you're writing for if it's not for
the audience if it's for yours
i mean yeah if you want to write for
yourself no problem but if you want your
movies to be successful
and you want you know to make a career
of it and and you know and be
financially comfortable
you got to consider the audience i mean
they're the people paying for it to
consume it
again if you have the luxury of not
worrying about that and not having to
make a living from it
then write for whoever you want right
for yourself but if you
have to make a living from your audience
because you want them to pay to consume
your product
you better cater to them what about the
purists though that
feel that their creation is is
and i'm i'm using cheap and too much so
i'm going to try to find a new word but
that it's being compromised compromised
i like that yeah it's good
compromise and and and changed by too
many hands
then maybe is is just making films
for those that are so precious about
their ideas
and they don't want too many you know
whether it's a test audience
you know exchange this part here that
maybe that is just best to make the film
in the sense the way you made your first
film uh with your grandfather's story
that it was something that you needed to
do and you really felt
felt contentment after you finished it
but you weren't there to try to sell it
in terms of it wasn't supposed to be
this million dollar idea right
and and that there are two kinds of
filmmakers and that that's okay
yeah it's definitely okay but um again
it depends what
financial comfort and luxury you have in
your life
if you're doing this to make a living
then you have to focus on the audience
if you're if you don't it's not about
making a living but it's it's an
artistic endeavor
that's either hobby or something that
it's not going to
change your life and you don't need it
to make income
then yeah you have to do whatever you
want to do but here's the advice i would
definitely give to independent
filmmakers
if you really have a message and and you
do have to make a living from it
but you really want to maintain that
artistic integrity which i
highly recommend you do write a book
don't make a movie a book is so much
cheaper
to write and to publish than it is to
make a movie
so why put yourself in that financial
predicament of making a movie
just write a book and and express
yourself exactly the way you want it to
and you'll have it forever and the world
will have it
and maybe you'll make a movie someday of
it now
there are filmmakers who do have the
luxury either by
happenstance or like coincidence or
or they were born into it or whatever um
have the luxury of doing whatever they
want to do
which is fantastic and when they do that
um sometimes it's absolutely brilliant
when they have no financial you know
considerations or no directions or
whatever they get to do what they want
to do
um it doesn't happen often but you know
it does happen after you've had a lot of
success like like tarantino nobody's
gonna tell him how to make a movie
anymore
and i'm not sure maybe the studios
didn't tell him at the beginning but
um when you have that proven success
and people you know are willing to bank
on your raw
talent that's great but usually out of
the gate with
independent filmmakers i mean a lot of
them do have that great raw talent
and and can hit a home run the first
time around but people don't know it
and it's it's super risky so making a
a movie and i'm talking when i say make
a movie i'm not talking you know fifty
thousand or a hundred thousand i'm
talking you know
eight hundred thousand nine hundred
million dollars or whatever there's real
money involved
and somebody's going to lose a lot of
money and if they can afford to and they
say no problem no problem great that's
fantastic
but if there's fine if people's you know
financial comfort is at stake i say
the audience says you got to really keep
that in consideration
you know you brought up book and forgive
me i'm reading this book about jd
salinger right now
and this woman who had a job at an
agency answering his fan mail and to see
that his fan mail spanned generations
and it was so
it was so much that they couldn't even
give it to him
he had to he he had sort of a shield up
because he had created something that
resonated with
so many generations of people and that's
something he probably
didn't intend on having happen he wrote
it sort of out of his own angst and
being in the war and different things
like that but that's one example of
of probably not intending to write for a
market but somehow
it was lightning in a bottle how how
rare is that
i don't know for sure because i would
say most independent writers and produce
and and directors and you know do write
for what the artistic merit of it they
have something that they want to express
and and they just write it um so i did
that
i mean that's what i did with my first
movie i wrote the script the way i
wanted it i didn't have to answer to any
studio exactly
i just had to answer them myself i did
it how i wanted to
now if i were to do it again do a remake
of it
i would probably do it a little
differently i would make it more
audience friendly
i would make i would pace it a little
differently i would cut it a little
differently i would
make it you know a little bit more
audience friendly because
the audience now i understand the
audience better
my brother's keeper sorry yeah my
brother's keepers i was to make that
again
so you know the first time around you
tend to believe that what you're
going to make is going to be so
artistically sound
that it will resonate with audiences and
you don't really have to
pay attention to them you just have to
be as creative as
and you know as possible um and and it
does work sometimes
it does but there are some trends and
some
you know things that people have learned
along the way that also work
that would be good to take into
consideration but it you know
artists could say that that is a
compromise but do you think that that's
good that you had that experience and
that
you knew a story you had to get out
there for your own personal reasons
and now you can resonate with a lot of
filmmakers who you probably have to have
that talk with them
because they they it's they're precious
with their idea
but you also know that they need to sell
certain territories and that might not
work in a territory yeah
remember i had like i said you know the
financial luxury of owning my own
business
and being financially comfortable so i
wouldn't have
also had four kids so i would not have
done that had i not had financial
comfort
behind me it it wasn't going to change
my lifestyle
but if it was if i i wasn't gonna
prepare listen
i had a dream and i wanted to live it
but i wasn't prepared to
roll the dice on the rest of my life on
my own family and my house and
everything like that that's still more
important to me
so um i guess i'm just that kind of guy
i'm super responsible that way and
i like to find the balance of living my
dreams and
how and one of my dreams is having nice
family and a nice family life right
so i got to keep that in balance um if
you have that in your life
then do what you need to do like just do
it your way
stay the vision do it exactly how you
want to do it and so because at the end
of the day
i mean two things are going to happen
one is it's either going to be
financially successful or not
but the at the end of the day what is
most important is
when you look back on that that's your
legacy in your life
you have to feel really good you can't
second guess yourself for the rest of
your life saying oh if i would have
stuck to my vision or if i would have
done this or i would have done that
i mean you have to say this is what i
wanted to do in my life this is why i'm
doing it
this is my dream i'm sacrificing so much
else i want to
keep the artistic integrity because
that's what i want to do that's the
message i want to do
so i strongly strongly encourage that
it's not you see it's the question is
what is a compromise everybody has a
different level where they draw that
line right
so for me if you know if here's 100
if i compromise 20 and i keep the other
80 percent
intact i feel okay i feel that that
wasn't too big of a compromise because
i know why i did that i'm going after a
certain audience and i need to pace it
differently
or i need to add a subplot in or i need
to do something that i wouldn't
otherwise do
artistically i don't like i'm never
going to regret that decision
because i have that financial business
side of me saying i know why i did it
i did it because i wanted to try to to
reach the audience
but if you're an artist who that will
bother you the rest of your life then
don't do it
don't do it and hope that what you've
done will resonate with your audience
because they never know for sure you can
follow patterns but
nothing's for sure for sure it's not set
in stone
sure and and some people live by
this motto that they don't want to be a
sellout
i know it gets a lot of i mean that
spans generations the cell whether it's
in music
um you know writing uh film but some
people you said
being okay with that 20 percent some
people might consider that 20
selling out oh 100 totally i mean some
people might consider one percent
selling out
and so you have to know who you are and
you got to feel confident
like i said when all is said and done i
mean the litmus test the true litmus
test
is five years later how do you feel
about what you did
not two months later not six months
later because you know you're going
through
let it sit and five years later come
back to it watch it again
how do you feel about it do you feel
like you sold out do you feel
that you made a mistake that you did
something wrong
that's about knowing yourself and
everybody has a different sort of level
at which they deal with
um so i would never sell myself out
like here's the here's the classic
example of that
as a studio or or you know a distributor
some
some corporation the film industry says
wow we read your script and we like it
and we want to make it but we don't want
you to direct it we want to put another
director on
and that other director is going to have
artistic
you know decision making on it that
is tricky right because you want your
movie made you want your story being
told you wrote your script you love it
but nine times out of ten they're not
going to tell it the way you told it
and then sometimes they might tell it
better but usually you're going to feel
compromised
so is that a compromise that's worth
doing i mean here
on the one side you're getting your
movie made it's a dream your script
you're
getting paid for it you're gonna see it
come to life but on the other side
you don't get to to it's like having a
baby
and giving that baby to someone else to
raise it so
you love the baby you're always gonna
love the baby but you don't like the
direction they raised it
is that a compromise depends who you are
and depends what you feel if you feel
it's a compromise then don't do it
if you feel it's not then do it and it's
good it's all per it's very personal
decision
script or budget what should someone
think of first when producing a film
karen i love your questions i really do
the business side of me says budget but
you can't ever deny script script is
look it
here's what i say to filmmakers i say
you got to be cognizant of how much you
spend because there's only so much you
can make back
but don't if you're if you want to make
money with a movie
don't make a bad movie like there's no
point in doing
something that's not going to entertain
an audience if it's
if it's a piece of crap then if you're
doing it because you want to practice
fine but if you're doing it because you
really want to try to give yourself a
shot
don't do a bad movie because a bad movie
can't sell
it's just so you can't compromise on
script for the sake of budget
but there's a range you see script is
not just here
it's a range it could be this is good
enough this is fantastic
so maybe you hopefully end up in the
middle or somewhere here
but you know at some point you have to
say okay i can't afford all the things i
want in here
because my budget won't allow me all
these explosions or gunshots or you know
in the case of an action movie all the
stuff you want to stick in here
but i have enough story here where i'm
prepared to go at this level
and i feel like i can make a good solid
entertaining movie
in the case of budget though you see if
you want to make your money back there
are
certain realities to the marketplace
that there's certain levels where it's
tried and true that you're only going to
make a certain amount back on certain
levels of movies
like for instance if you're not using a
level talent you're just using no name
talent
it peaks out at a certain level unless
you know we're i'm not talking about the
anomalies the home runs that come into
left field that you nobody expects it
okay i'm talking about the regular
everyday movies
all right for the most part you're only
going to get back
say this amount of money for for for a
budget at this
like make a million dollar movie chances
are
the highest prospect you have is a
million and a half dollars out there
if you and if you think that's a million
and a half is what i can really get
once you creep you start creeping that
budget up to a million two
three four five or go over that
even if you are super successful the
market won't bear anything more than
that
therefore you're putting yourself in a
predicament where you probably won't
make money
where you could have made money if you
stuck to that million dollar budget
now then it becomes script like your
filmmaker there's the integrity i need
that one extra explosion
i need that one extra big scene you know
to make this movie more epic
and maybe win an award or something like
that
and maybe it does make the movie better
but i'm not sure it increases the
revenue on the back end
until you get into sort of the next
category of film
so i tend to lean budget is always the
controlling factor because
because i don't want to lose money but
script is a very very they're related
right what can you do it's basically the
question always is
here's how much money realistically you
have to spend either because that's what
investors gave you or that's you don't
want to spend more because that's what
you can earn back
what can i do in this story for that
amount of money
will i feel compromised that i couldn't
do enough
don't make that movie then let me see if
i understand this so
if i have a film and i know that the
budget is a million dollars
great stay at that level because there's
there's a chance i couldn't recruit my
investors money and and
make a profit but if i start to move the
needle and do a few more things here
and we're going up now 200 000 now i'm
putting
that money at risk there's a chance that
that's not going to be a safe investment
but if i had an uh what would be the
higher the next highest
so two million yeah it's categories so
first of all and again it's not a
perfect science it's just based on my
experience right
so this a classic filmmaker will say you
know like let's use a million dollars
right you're making action film for a
million dollars
all right you really want two million
dollars because you want to add in all
these other
big you know special effects and stuff
like that but you don't have it
the distributor says a million and a
half is
the realistic place that revenue that
we're going to get for this movie
so try to keep it there once you start
spending that extra
then you here's what a filmmaker says
but if i spend an extra 200 000 i put
that big
scene in that big explosion scene then
you're gonna get 2 million for the movie
not 1.5
and the distributor says maybe we know
we're going to get 1.5
we might get two but if we don't you've
just eaten up 200 000
worth of profit of your profit so
do you want to take that chance and then
the filmmaker says yeah because
i know what's going to happen and the
distributor says well we've sold 500
movies like this and it's only happened
for one
what you know you're sure you want to
roll the dice on that because
it's a very very risky decision so i
tend to be super pragmatic and i say
it's not worth it's not worth the
business side of it
let's just talk about budget for a
second right
there's there's so many ways to make a
budget all right
let's talk about three classic ways to
make a budget this is this is the crazy
part about it
like i keep saying okay a million
dollars because it's a round number
right
so how do you get to a million dollars i
mean the classic way that's taught in
film school and that most filmmakers use
and studios use this is the classic way
you take the script you break it down
you schedule it you break it down into
shooting days all your elements your
locations you know your actors all that
kind of stuff you do it as a script
breakdown right and from that you see
what it's going to cost you budget all
the elements
and then you come up with a number and
let's say that number
is a million two by somebody doing it
the proper way by doing it that way
that's what i call front end budgeting
all right
a million two is the number no there's
some wiggle room here or there
you know you're gonna use this card that
blow up or something else or whatever
there's a few things that you know come
into play but a million two is your
number right
then here's another way to do it you say
that realistically your uncle
left you a million dollars and that's
the
only amount of money you're gonna have
to spend nobody else is gonna ever give
you another dime
you have a million dollars to spend but
you just got a budget for a million too
does that mean you don't make the movie
or does it mean
that your financial resource is a
million dollars so you figure out how to
cut out 200 000
and now your budget's a million dollars
so that's what i call back end
you have a million dollars now you want
to just make as good a movie as you can
for a million dollars
do you do it like that's the question
right
then the third way is what i was talking
about before which is
the market the people who do the
marketing say
the most you could possibly sell this
for is you know a million three
so don't spend more than a million
because we're going to need some 300 000
of wiggle room or something like that
if you want to be financially successful
and which you do
so now you go with the market and they
say you can't spend more than that
that's
that's what you have to make this movie
for in order to be successful
which one do you go with you're a
filmmaker which one do you go with
the first way at a million two is where
you gonna get the money from
like is somebody gonna actually finance
it the second way somebody said i got a
million dollars you spend a million make
a good movie we're good to go
the third way is you're being super
fiscally
it's being led by the market conditions
that's a
business decision can you make a movie
that you know has artistic merit within
that
range so these things all factor in
into this realistically if you want to
get a movie made
now there's a lot of filmmakers who say
to me
this is my script this is the breakdown
this is the number
it's a million seven and there's no
wiggle room
that's the number and i say wonderful
you're probably going to lose money on
the movie you may never get it financed
but hopefully you will and you'll make a
great movie and
and that's fantastic but you know you
hear the stories of people who spend
10 15 20 years of their life chasing
that dream
um now on the flip side of that
you know there's you're making an action
film and it requires a million dollars
to do it properly
and people say no and i'm gonna do it
for a hundred thousand and i say
that's great do it for practice because
i don't care how good a filmmaker you
are
the chances of you making a you know the
production value style of what needs to
be a million dollars for a hundred
thousand dollars is extremely low
yes people have done it yes i know all
the examples the el mariachis and
and the blair witches and i know all of
them they're anomalies
they're one out of fifty thousand or a
hundred thousand
don't make a business decision based on
those
you know people winning the lottery like
everybody talks about the people who won
the lottery nobody talks about the
hundreds of millions of people who
didn't win the lottery
so that's it depends what business
decision you want to make
that was a long answer for that question
how many filmmakers accept that
all studio filmmakers accept it because
they have to because they're
responsible to you know to deliver a
bottom line
and a very small sector of indie
filmmakers
accept that i mean they're forced to
accept it
because if they actually want to make
something that there's only a certain
amount of money that you know they have
access to
so i'd say if you want to talk about
compromise in the indie film market
most people are making stuff well and
for budgets well below
what they really should make it for and
then it comes out badly not because
they're not good filmmakers they're
actually really good filmmakers
but they didn't have the resources to
make the film properly so it comes out
badly
and then that becomes sort of their
calling card and they made a bad film
and then it's
you know in some ways almost a negative
you know it's as crazy as this sound
it's almost better to make those films
and not put your name on it
just do it because you need to practice
and hone your skills but
don't put your name on it because it's
not necessarily your best foot forward
to get money for your next film
i know that sounds nuts but no no i've
heard other
like authors say you know just accept
that your your first book will
not probably probably won't be a
bestseller probably won't do
anything substantial and i think it's
just like reconciling that with yourself
and knowing okay
i'm probably not going to be this
anomaly i'm not going to you know i know
i want to be
but i'm going to accept the fact that i
can still do this but my first one is
not going to be this like
great success yeah but the beauty of the
film business this is what is so
attractive
attractive for the film is it's this
this dream this glamour this glory
i mean it's so infectious you know
people
dream of that and all it's i call it the
hollywood dream
that you can be the anomaly you can be
that one
crazy breakthrough hit um
and not not every business has that this
business does offer that
and that's what all indie filmmakers
have that dream
and you know some of them get to live it
not many but some do
sure and then there's just something
satisfying about being in a theater
renting it out
seeing it with an audience having a q a
having an after party
if you're able to afford that and and
being okay with that
yeah you know it's funny what you just
described being in an audience renting
out a theater having a party all that
kind of stuff
that's good the first time around the
second time around
the only thing you're the first time
around you're you're in heaven you're
listening to the audience you're
the movie opens and they clap and
there's a q and a
it's greatest experience right the
second time around
all you're thinking about is how much
that theater costs you how much the hors
d'oeuvres cost you how much people are
drinking
how much what the bill at the end of the
day is going to be even though you
enjoyed the movie and you enjoyed that
but
after a while it becomes like can i
afford this
so the party's fun the first time and
then
the the second third and beyond it stops
being about
the party's always fun because parties
are fun and you're celebrating a work of
art that you just created
you're you're having a baby like you
just brought a new baby into the world
and that's a celebration so the party's
always fun don't get me wrong i enjoy
every party and i have a party for every
film because i want to celebrate it
that's the celebration
it's not the business though some people
think it's the business
some people think going to a film
festival and sitting through a big
screening and everybody doing the q
a and everything like that that's a
party
and it's a nice party it's a nice
celebration and sometimes it's the only
celebration you get
for me the celebration is getting a
really big check from a streaming
company
because i sold the movie and then seeing
it on the the first time you see it on a
stream
like on netflix or something like that
that's a party
that's a real party i mean that to me is
for me
sitting in my you know family room with
my family
and watching it the first time it comes
onto a streaming company and knowing
that i got paid for it
that to me is a celebration now the
other stuff is really fun
and i enjoy it and don't get me wrong i
like a good party like everybody else
how does a filmmaker know how much to
spend in order to get their money back
great question this is where filmmakers
you know get upset with distributors
because they usually get screwed by
distributors that's the truth
because distribution's a whole different
business mindset
they don't have the you know the the
sensitivity to filmmakers but
distributors do serve a very good
function in the in the
industry i mean they do know how much a
movie is worth
where to monetize it where to sell it
and they have a pretty good idea of how
much they're going to get for it
so the best way to find out you know
what sort of
the range will be will be through a
distributor
now there are sales agents um who do
these forecasts for you they give you
these ranges most indie films when
they're
you know trying to get financed they'll
get a sales agent to do a range
i've seen so many of them i don't know
if you've seen them but there's the low
the middle and the high sometimes
there's five of them right
their forecasts based on you know other
like films or comparisons i mean you
have to be super careful that you're
comparing it to like films
in the same sort of time frame like
sometimes they'll compare
to like films that were released 10
years ago well i mean 10 years ago was a
completely different market than today
right
so you want the comps to be as you know
accurate as possible
but they'll do these comparisons and
they'll say you know the middle range is
sort of what you can expect
and it sort of is what you can expect i
mean these are people that do this for a
living they know
where ultimately they're going to sell
it what the market will bear
you know internationally and from each
player
and they do forecasts that give you a
pretty good idea
not dead on but at least a range and
that that's the best way to
gauge it so similar to how a realtor
would run
comps on on well this is a fixer and
it's this is
the square footage and so i think yours
will go for this or this one is
you know you've just redone the kitchen
and bathroom and you've got a huge lot
similar correct that's exactly the same
thing i mean i think real estate's a
little bit more
predictable and accurate because it's
confined area you know
whereas film is the whole world but it's
the same concept
does that mean if i pick up the phone
and just call a distributor they'll give
me an idea of what my budget should be
um not necessarily i mean we should talk
a little bit about distributors and how
to find a distributor
and you know who's reputable and who
will give you you know the right answer
assuming they'll even answer your phone
call um
there are one you can pay for this there
are services that provide that
they charge a lot and i think they're a
bit of a rip off i mean i only think
that because i do my own forecast based
on my own
you know market knowledge um but if you
don't have any access to anything else
then you can pay for that
um and i forget there's some big
companies that actually do that
they provide those forecasts and they do
comp reports i mean
you know they're fancy and they give you
the whole thing and you take those to
investors and say here i got this report
done from
this company who specializes in this and
they're credible
um there's sales agents so there's a
difference between a sales agent and a
distributor i mean that line is
sort of crossing over these days a
little bit more
but an agent will say this is what they
can
tell you sort of what to expect
and they're easier to get to than
distributors a distributor
generally wants to look at the movie
when it's
finished and that's why they're harder
to get to they don't really want to look
at the script or the idea
or be pitched on it
they would be able to tell you and if
you can get to them you know
and we can talk a minute about how to
get to them then you can say i want to
make a
you know a 800 000 horror film and it's
going to have
this number of special effects and no
talent then they can say
expect to get you know eight hundred
thousand or a million or whatever they
they could
they could say they could say that in
off the cuff over a coffee
they don't need to go and do analysis or
anything like that these people know
this
in you know this is what they do so how
do you get how do you find a distributor
and how do you get an
honest answer it's getting tougher and
tougher to find a reputable distributor
first of all that business is getting
tougher so i mean this
the world is changing people's viewing
habits are changing so
so consumption of movies is changing i
mean
a lot of it now is through the streamers
through the
subscription video on demand services
the netflix the hulu's you know the
disney pluses
um it's easy for consumers they're
spending you know
five to ten dollars a month and getting
an incredible array of
fantastic product it's made movie
watching such a pleasure
and television look at the quality of
product they're getting on some of these
i mean it's incredible
the amount you know that these streamers
spend on product because it's a volume
game they can afford it right
so that's making distribution top more
difficult so distributors are
falling by the wayside also so they're
getting far and fewer between
and they generally want to deal with
bigger budget product
they're not crazy about dealing with low
budget product for the same reason a
real estate agent
is not as crazy about you know doing a
hundred thousand dollar rent
sale then at five million dollar sale
same amount of work
much less commission so they want to
deal with bigger stuff because
you know they'll make more money off of
it but to find a reputable distributor
i mean you know you start um
there's different ways you can go about
it depending on who you are and what
your resources are
i mean you can go to a market like the
american film market or something like
that register for it
it's not cheap but that will give you a
access to all the distributors who are
registered there plus
access to their guide who's registered
in the american film marketing
association
you can do the same with say you know
read medium who runs mip.com or that
type of thing
so once you get into their database like
when you register
as a buyer or seller or whatever an
attendee for a major market like that
the value is half the value is going to
the market and you know hobnobbing and
seeing what goes on the other half is
having access to the database so then
now you have this
say with the case of miptv or mipcom
um you know there's two to three
thousand distributors in that book
and in their database so now you gotta
contact them you to reach out
and it's like any type of networking you
you
try to be brief explain you know that
you're filmmaker making this kind of
movie
here's what it's going to be you know
dress it up a little bit you got to sell
yourself a bit
and say um you just want to you're
interested in taking it to them
after the movie's finished but you want
to get an indication of
sort of what budget range you should be
working in to make sure that
you're not going to you know you have a
chance of actually recouping and they'll
some of them will be cooperative like
anything else in the world you know half
of them will be rude
and the other ones you know you then you
just hopefully get lucky and you
get somebody on the phone who's you know
nice and will give you
they're not even on the phone through an
email or whatever the case may be
and if you can't do it that way you're
gonna have to pay to get a report
and and with this report some of the
comps again special effects
no name talent what about like locations
how many locations you plan to shoot
things like that
um is that is that factor in everything
factors in depending on who you get
because
it's also subjective but it doesn't
really totally factor in i mean the main
component is talent if you have a
certain level of talent then
it elevates it into a different category
see
like there are there's there's ranges
it's not you know like a total linear
thing
so in my i personally think and again
this is just
everything just my opinion right okay
but from my experience
if you're dealing in low-budget indie
films stay below
about 1.5 maximum
i used to say 2 million but 1.5 max
because the market is getting tougher
and tougher and tougher to monetize that
between 1.5 if once you start getting
into that
if you don't have major talent like at
least somebody who is recognizable
then you're better off jumping into 5
million
like between 1.5 and 5 is almost no
man's land unless you can figure out how
to get talent in there
you have a better chance of getting your
money back if you do say a 5 million
movie that has name talent then you do
of doing a three million dollar movie
that's really really well done but
doesn't have name talent
because talent sells talent's a huge
fact most distributors the first
question they
ask is who's in it and the reason that's
they asked that is because most
consumers
ask that they say hey i heard this movie
who's in it
that's 90 of what people ask who's in it
and when they when they recognize
somebody they might take a chance with
it
so if you do go to afm uh or or mipcom
or something like that
then you you would look at the
distributors and make sure you're
reaching out to ones that are going to
be in your genre like don't if you have
a rom-com don't go to only
horror yeah and if you have a narrative
don't go to a documentary you know
some people only specialize in factual
some and you know non-scripted you know
yeah there are spec those are all listed
also they're all categorized
people when they list when the
distributors list in the in the uh
databases
you know they fill out a form and they
say this is who we are this is what we
sell this is what we specialize in
yeah so try to you know hone in on that
on the distributor that would
be you know more most suitable to what
you're making and keep the email brief
it's funny i'm talking so much right now
but generally
i write super brief emails and i keep my
correspondence super brief
and that's because we live in a world of
super short attention spans now i mean
people don't like to read a lot
everything's sound bites everything is
super quick everything is you know
twitter feeds and and instagram posts
and stuff like that it's all
super super short and with younger
executives
who you know are now used to all this
technology
they just don't want to read long emails
and don't want to hear long pitches and
all this kind of stuff
get to the point quickly
what's the best way to spend money on a
movie well if you're talking from a
filmmaker's point of view who's making a
movie let's start with that
okay as opposed to a distributor who's
acquiring a movie um
so you want to spend the money
like i believe you should put most of it
on screen
meaning that you know there's a lot of
stuff that goes on behind the scenes in
production
um i here's the classic example is
is catering so everybody likes to be fed
well on
set and i believe in that because you
know people eat well they're happy
but you can get really good catering and
quality food
for a lot less than you know there's a
big range
right i don't believe on an indie film
that you need to have a chef
they're preparing food and serving it
and all that kind of stuff was what
you'd see on a big hollywood film
you can have a nice good hot quality
meal
for a fraction of the price and that
does not go on screen
now there are filmmakers who argue with
me and say it does sort of go on screen
because if they're happy with the meal
they will perform better after lunch
and i say give them a good hearty
healthy meal and you're going to be fine
but don't overspend there because it's
not
like if you want to spend you know up
the ante on your wardrobe
on some of your props on some of your
special effects people are gonna see
that
put you know five more extras in your
scene as opposed to an extra dish on
your catering
so that i think as an indie filmmaker
you have to be super prudent about that
kind of thing
and very very very careful you want to
put as much on screen as possible
as a distributor acquiring a movie where
should you spend your money there
well obviously you're going to try to
acquire
the movie that you think is going to be
the most marketable and that's based on
what's trending in the marketplace and
what your customers have been buying
so you know you're gonna go looking for
stuff that you think you can sell
that's all it is it's no different than
a real estate agent you don't have to
fall in love
a distributor doesn't doesn't have to
love the movie they're selling as a
matter of fact
as much as you think this is crazy nine
times out of ten they don't even watch
the movies
they don't need to watch them they need
a trailer that's it
um it's like you know the real estate
agent does not have to love the house
they're selling they don't have to live
in it
they just have to find somebody who does
and that's what a distributor does they
just have to find a customer for it
but a realtor does often do an open
house most people
but that's just to give access to
potential buyers sure you know
that would be a distributor does a
screening to give access to potential
buyers so they so the re let's i'm just
surprised that most distributors would
not
fully watch the movie why would you need
to i i guess what if what because you
know sometimes trailers are way better
than the film and then there's the
opposite
generally speaking but generally you see
a trailer the trailer is not better than
the film
it should be better it should tell that
story very quickly i mean that's the
whole point of a trailer
i know it's disappointing for for indie
filmmakers to hear that but
it's the truth i used to go to afm and
as a buyer
this is before i went as a filmmaker for
years years and years and years
i'm talking like 20 years of afms and i
sat in all the theaters
and i would watch i don't know within a
week i'd
easily see well over 100 movies i mean
how do you watch 100 movies in a week
without so
you'd you'd go in you'd watch the first
if in the first 10 minutes you weren't
intrigued you'd go and you go to the
next screening you have to get
you have to be captured in the first 10
minutes if you are intrigued
you watch the first 20 minutes and then
you request a screener
and then depending on how much you're
spending on the movie to acquire it
you either don't watch any more of it if
it's a very you know inexpensive
acquisition or maybe no money at all no
minimum guarantee if you're going to
spend a lot then you watch the movie
you want to make sure that the whole
thing flows
terrible terrible but true wow there's
because
limited time and and you only you know
how many movies can you watch
distribution confidential okay
some distributors are going to watch
this film and say hey that's baloney
you know i we watch everything and and
you know i'm being honest with you
in my distribution company we watched
part of everything but there was very
few that you'd watch through the end
unless you're really really intrigued by
it but listen
how many times have you bought an item a
piece of clothing or something like that
that you like
um and somebody else doesn't like it
nobody you don't have to love everything
that you're selling you just have to
know that there's somebody out there who
will
who will like it you just have to get it
to them
what are three key points every
filmmaker should know about getting a
movie meet
i would say point number one and this is
remember i'm talking about a filmmaker
who has the intention to make money
okay to sell their film because if their
intention is just to create
a movie that is artistic that they want
to finish and put on their shelf and
enjoy
that's not what i'm talking about so if
we're talking about somebody who
has makes a movie the intention of
making a profit on it selling it and
hopefully making a profit
the first thing they should do they have
to
they have to think about who they're
going to sell it to who the audience is
who they're making the movie for
that's number one number two is
so number one is identifying the
audience number two is
how they gonna market to that audience
so now they know what audience they want
to get to
but how they gonna get there how are
they going to
what publicity campaign what social
media campaign whatever
are they going to use to get to that
audience
now you might be thinking yourself you
asked me about
you know about making a movie and i'm
talking about selling a movie
i honestly believe that if you want to
make money with your movie
as i would say for any business or any
product not just a movie
you got to be thinking about your
audience and how to market them
before you even make your movie and then
number three would be how to deploy your
funds
as effectively as possible so that
you're getting as we talked about before
the most
of your money on screen so you're making
the best product possible
don't waste your time and make a crappy
product you'll regret it and it won't
sell
so make what you make something that
you're going to be proud of that you
feel like you're going to you know have
a shot to sell
but before you do that make sure you
know who you're making it for and that
you have it
and you have an avenue to get to them
whether it be through a distributor
or through your own means or through
your own you know friends or whatever
marketing you're gonna do
now i tell people this this is this is
where
indie filmmakers really really struggle
with what i'm about to say and this is
what i say to them
i say when you're budgeting for a movie
make sure that if you want to be
successful
if your movie is going to spend if
you're going to spend five hundred
thousand dollars on making your movie
spend at least at least three hundred
thousand dollars on marketing
it like you have to have like 60
somewhere between 60 and 100 of your
production budget you also have to have
for a marketing budget
and they say that's crazy how are we
going to do that we can hardly raise
enough money
to make the movie how are we gonna raise
money to market the movie
and i say if you want to have a shot
like if you want to compare yourself to
hollywood movies and studio movies
look at what they do i mean everything
every single movie they put out
has a gigantic marketing budget in some
cases it's you know the
the production budget and the marketing
budget are the same even on a 50 million
dollar movie
marketing budget might be more actually
i mean that's what makes it successful
because hollywood movies understand i
mean studios understand that
it's one thing to make a great movie but
it's it's nothing unless you can
get it in front of an audience and you
have to advertise it to them
indie filmmakers don't necessarily do
that so remember the two
things that i led with were know who
your audience is and make sure you have
you know
the wherewithal to get to them which is
usually involves resources
so make sure that when you're budgeting
you
tuck a big chunk of money aside for
marketing now it's funny i've listened
to a lot of your webcasts here and a lot
of filmmakers talk about it and they
talk about
make sure you have enough money i mean
most people say make sure you have
enough money for post-production
when i listen to those and i say are you
kidding me
like post-production is part of making
the movie like you actually went and
shot a film and didn't think about
post-production like that's
crazy then then to me it's crazy like i
would never do that i would never go
into production
without having enough money to finish
the movie because what's the point of
that
secondly some people who are you know
little further along
say make sure you have enough for
delivery because it's expensive to
deliver
you have to you know there's elements
you have to do to deliver
i also say of course you have to deliver
i mean that's all part of like that's
part of the production budget
but how many indie filmmakers ever say
make sure you have enough to market
and it's painful to say that it's
actually painful because
if you have an extra quarter of a
million dollars and you're sitting
and you know it's tucked away there for
marketing you're inclined to spend it on
the movie
i'll make a way better movie i'll spend
five quarter million dollars more
think of how i could spend it think of
how good the movie could be but then you
got nothing left to market it with
so no matter how good a movie you made
you yeah you can't market it
now here's what you'll ask me and here's
what everybody says but that's the
distributor's job to market it it's not
my job to market it it's the distributor
so i'm going to get a distributor
and they're going to spend the quarter
of a million dollars to market it that's
what they do
and i say maybe that means
first of all i got to get lucky and get
a distributor secondly
there aren't too many distributors these
days who are going to spend a quarter
million dollars marking an indie movie
so you better like if you really really
want to get behind your movie
and and you really believe in it and you
want to have a shot at getting it
successful
tuck that money aside raise extra money
put it in
and tell your investors they'll actually
respect that they will respect the fact
that you're actually thinking about
marketing
as much as you're thinking about
production tuck it aside
and if you do get a distributor if you
do get lucky and get a good distributor
have them deploy those resources on your
behalf
so that they have you know a war chest
to help get the movie out it's only
going to be to your benefit
i mean there are some tricks on how to
make that happen so they don't
beat you and take fees on your own money
and take costs and all that kind of
stuff we'll have to talk about that at
some point
um so like don't just throw it in their
laps because they'll spend it and you
won't get any return on it
but if and and the other thing is if you
don't get a distributor
you may have to self-distribute and if
you're going to self-distribute you need
to have
some resources to do that with it it's
not good enough to throw out you know
just a crappy
social media campaign these days it's
too crowded out there nobody's going to
see it
you have to spend some money well what
about cream rises to the top
so if i get it on one of these streaming
services it's
it i don't need to it's gonna it's gonna
don't worry it'll be suggested yeah
that's the typical thing
if if i get it on a streaming service do
you know what the odds of getting in on
a streaming service
are that would be like if i or people
say if i get it into sundance
then you know you know a big company
will see it and i will let's talk about
sundance that's okay that's like the
streaming company all right
it's the same type of deal right getting
a movie into an indie movie into
sundance now is almost impossible
i mean it the acceptance rate is so low
it's like getting accepted to ucla for
college students like 114 000
applications and
3 000 spots it's extremely extremely low
all right so the chances of you getting
accepted in descendants with your indie
film
are very very low but let's say you're
one of the lucky ones and you actually
do get it in
all right that's not enough because the
next thing you have to do
is you have to get a screening time
that like it's it's about getting the
screening where buyers will actually
come
so i'm using sundance because it's one
of the major festivals and we know that
there are lots of
acquisition executives and you know and
movie buyers who could make a difference
who could make your movie
but it has to be seen you have to spend
a
fortune you have to hire a publicist
first of all you have to
hopefully get a good screening time if
it's nine in the morning and there's
parties the night before
nobody's coming to your screening so you
have to get an afternoon or i mean
that's hard to do
right you got to get lucky with that now
you get that so now you've gotten lucky
twice
you have to hire a publicity team and a
you know a promotion team
you can't just assume people are going
to come somebody's got to be talking it
up that costs a lot of money to hire
those people
especially at sundance where it's super
competitive and where it's hard to get
the attention of the buyers because they
only want to see the big movies
so that's when i said a lot of money
that could be anywhere from five to ten
thousand dollars
minimum minimum all right not to mention
you have to be at sundance and spend
your money to be there and all that kind
of stuff
so now you get the buyers there likely
your publicity person will say you have
to have a party because afterwards you
have to entertain them and they have to
schmooze with you and blah blah blah
blah blah
there's another 10 to 20 grand maybe
down the toilet
but this is what you're competing with
this is what studios do so it's not like
oh everybody says i'll get into sundance
and i'll be setting you know and then
you got to hope that somebody's in a
good mood and that they liked your
champagne
and it was expensive enough that they
want to make you an offer
so there's a lot that goes into it same
with the streaming service what
you think you pick up the phone and call
netflix and say oh i just made a great
film oh that's great send it over you
know
it doesn't work that way you could wait
years and years and years before
anybody even sees it so or you can get
lucky
but you can't i don't depend on luck
should a filmmaker think about where
they're going to sell their film
before they make it absolutely
absolutely
i mean there's the there's the plan and
there's the wishful thinking
so the plan is if all else fails
let's start with the bottom the lowest
common denominator i mean
we'll start with the top it's easier
okay the top would be
go to a festival get accepted into a big
festival get your movie seen by a big
movie company
they make you an offer they take it off
your hands give you a big amount of
money and
life is really good do not depend on
that
i'm not saying it can't happen it likely
won't happen
all right um and they you know they'll
sell it to all the right players and
you're done
all right so let's say that doesn't
happen i hope it does happen for
all you indie filmmakers but if it
doesn't which it likely won't
plan number two get it into a lower
level festival
now that's more of a celebration because
buyers don't really attend those
festivals but you can get some audience
feedback and get some
buzz maybe some critical you know maybe
some you know
awards something like that that that'll
help you to get the attention
then you got to get into the
distribution cycle so
the distribution cycle is either finding
a distributor
or sales agent um do you want me to
explain the difference between a sales
agent and a distributor
sure okay so a sales agent i mean again
they're melding into sort of one in the
same these days
but a sales agent generally finds you a
distributor
a distributor generally finds um places
your
your film in the homes of where people
are going to view it like ie the
streaming services the broadcasters
whatever
a distributor is we call them destroy
because they get the movie out they
distribute the movie out to
the places where it will get consumed
which is primarily television
now streaming and video on demand all
right and you know
airlines and all that kind of stuff
whereas a sales agent
doesn't deal necessarily with
broadcasters and streamers
they deal with distributors so sometimes
it's hard to get to distributors because
especially before the fact before you
make your movie they want to deal only
with finished films
and they don't have a lot of time and
they want to deal with bigger budget
films so it's it's often
very very tricky to navigate that and
they're they're a bit of a peen in the
butt to be honest with you
um and they're not responsive and
they're um some of them aren't even
credible
so it's usually easier to get through a
sales agent
who can represent you into a distributor
the problem with that is you're going to
pay two levels of commissions
you're going to pay the sales agent
their commission which is somewhere
between 10 and 15 percent
generally then a distributor is going to
take somewhere between 20 and 30 percent
now some will ask for 35 or 40 but uh
you know in a second i'm going to talk
about what not to
accept in a distribution deal so so
you're adding
an extra level of distribution and an
extra you know
level of transmission of funds and
everything starts to get diluted
but if you don't have any other way to
get there then you know that you have
to do that but let's say that fails too
let's say you can't get a distributor
let's say you can't get a sales agent to
get you a distributor for whatever
reason nobody's available you've asked
everybody and they're just not
responsive
that leaves you to self-distribute now i
personally believe in self-distribution
because i have a lot of distribution
experience and i
am a bit of a control freak i like to do
it my way and
you know i respect the fact that people
are doing jobs but if i don't like to
pay commissions for
when people don't do their job properly
so self distribution is tricky
it's hard to navigate but it's not
any trickier than making a movie i mean
you just finished making a movie you
spent your life doing that and your
resources and you navigated all that
so you just got to get creative you got
to switch gears and you have to say okay
now i'm going to get creative in
marketing
and i'm going to try to get out to an
audience the problem is is that most
creative artistic people feel that
that's a business function and they
don't do that
that's one is they don't like to do it
two is they don't know how to do it
three is they don't want to do it so
that means you're kind of stuck where do
you go what do you do
i mean you you don't have a home for
your movie
and then you get aggravated and
frustrated which is you know a lot of
indie stories you hear about that
right so
you wait and you wait and wait and hope
that i mean
you hope that something happens but it
usually doesn't so you kind
the good news about the digital era
right now is that
it's not that hard to self-distribute
i'm not saying it's going to be
that successful but like for instance
putting your movie up on amazon
and i'm not talking amazon prime the
streaming side of it i'm talking about
prime video you know the transactional
side
is real easy i mean you send it in you
fill it in a submission thing
they review it it's not that hard to do
you know i have to make delivery you
have to make sure you can deliver the
elements they need and and the trailer
and
the artwork and that kind of stuff but
you just made a movie you should be able
to do that
you should be capable of doing that i
know you're not going to like it i know
an indie filmmaker is not going to love
doing it
um so and if you don't then find
somebody who does find a friend find a
marketing person
find somebody who will take that on and
help out
and would you need eno insurance before
you do that or
is that a requirement of being on some
of those platforms
yeah you know is primarily
i mean you have to have you know if
you're on any television and
any streamer because they they want to
be you know they want to be covered with
that liability
so you know it's errors and emissions by
the way for people who don't know
and that is if you did something that
you weren't supposed to do like you
showed
a you depicted a character a name of
person or some building or something
like that you weren't
licensed to do that you could get sued
and the television station doesn't want
to
carry that liability of being sued for
that so that's what that insurance
covers
generally speaking these the
transactional
video on demand or don't ask for you
know that's not one of the criteria but
you know it's a really good question to
be honest with you i've never not had
you know
everything i just automatically get you
know because i sell to streaming
companies
um but i'm going to need to look into
that whether or not you need
eno for transactional video on demand
i don't know with eno insurance are
there different levels
different packages yeah yeah it goes by
it's like any type of insurance that
goes by how much coverage you want
so you know usually the minimum it used
to be a million dollars these days and
it's
now i believe it up to about 3 million
for major broadcasters
so they want their liability level to be
at 3 million per incident
and then 10 million cumulatively if
there are multiple incidents
those are standard packages um that's
for indie films
um that's the coverage right that's not
the policy the policy
can go anywhere depending on it's
negotiable right this is like buying any
insurance
it's like buying health insurance or
home insurance or in like that you know
it's a range
but within the range there's a couple of
bells and whistles like what's your
deductible
deductible going to be i mean there's a
deductible right so
it's no different than buying any other
insurance but
generally speaking a broadcast will want
it at a certain range which is about 3
million
minimum unless it's a big big big show
and might be 5 million
something like that and how long would
one need the policy to be in effect
great question so um
generally if there's going to be an
error
or a mission or something like that it
will be seen within the first two years
it will generally be seen within the
first two years of it going on to some
type of broadcasting thing
so generally these policies are two to
three years um some people take them for
five
sometimes even ten years just because
they're selling over and over to
different people and and
other people request it but also in the
case of an indie film
you're generally going to get like one
selling cycle like it's going to go
out there is going to get sold and you
don't really have to buy coverage
for what will be down the line if you're
lucky enough and there's like it comes
say you sell to netflix and it's a
three-year four-year deal right and it
comes off in netflix
don't buy another four years up front
until netflix renews if netflix or news
and they say hey you need more you know
then go and buy that
you know for the for the second period
there's no point in
spending the money now even though it's
cheaper obviously to buy it
longer term but you may not need it for
a second term
i believe you have three movies
currently on netflix
did you pitch all of those movies
yourself to netflix
okay so the three movies so first of all
full out is the first movie it's a
gymnastics movie
the second one is called kiss and cry
it's a skating movie and the first one
the third one is called fallout 2 you
got this
which is actually starting on january
1st so it's already sold and delivered
to netflix but they're actually starting
airing it on january 1st
it it's another gymnastics move they
were supposed to start it during the
olympics
last summer but of course there were no
olympics so they held it until january
so but they're all i say it's on because
it's delivered
and that's when it's going to start
worldwide so did i so i pitched
luckily back then when i pitched the
first one they were open to hear pitches
from independent producers
i got lucky because the timing they were
big company but they weren't what they
are today
so they were still taking pitches from
indie producers
so i went in there and i pitched them
myself
and you know i learned a lot it's it's
it's a
whole different style they get so many
pitches i didn't know this back then
you got to keep those pitches really
short get to the point really sweet
because they had so many of them that
they get tired of hearing them
so they just want to make a quick
decision and hear what you got to say
so i pitched it i pitched it too long i
had like a half an hour meeting and i
probably took 20 minutes to pitch that
other than you know 10 minutes of
pleasantries
today i pitch in two minutes two to
three minutes max that's all i
that's all it takes because they they
generally know right
so i pitched it and they said okay
sounds good we like it
let's do it but we don't want to take
delivery
from you because you're an indie
producer
we want to take delivery from a
distribution company that we're already
set up to do business with
because we don't want to set you up as a
new client in our database
it's too much work for us so i said but
i'm also a distributor
i have my own distribution company and
i make delivery i'm like i make perfect
delivery
to the distributors or two i'm making
delivery to broadcasters around the
world so
delivery delivery's not an issue and
they said yeah but we're so busy we have
so much going on
we would prefer that we put you through
a distributor and i said
i don't have a problem with that except
for they're going to charge me a full
fee for doing nothing i mean i pitched
you i did the sale
you want the movie i'm gonna have to pay
their full commission
and they said jeff you seem like a sharp
guy figure it out
go negotiate it figure it out so they
gave me a list of
like six or seven distributors that they
recommended who i could do business with
i met with two of them i chose one of
them and i
cut a good deal but not a fantastic deal
because
i had no leverage they knew that i was
sent there so
i had to deliver through another
distributor
and i was kind of a little peeved by it
but you know what it was netflix that's
what they wanted and
what am i going to argue i mean you know
so that i had i had to do that deal
and it worked out well the the other
people they did the deal
then the action happened to be a good
distributor they did some other deals
too and it worked out pretty well so i
can't complain about it
so the second time around same thing go
to netflix
pitch them on the movie love it let's do
it
i said guys please don't make me go
through a distributor
they said jeff you know the rules you've
got to go through a distributor
i said how many times do we have to go
down this anyways
same thing happens i go i use a
different distributor this time
because now it's different times i
actually make you know a different type
of deal and it works up
third time around
let's do it please let me just deliver
to you please let me deliver to you
if i fail i said listen if i feel don't
even pay me the licensing fee if i don't
deliver on time
per exactly for your specs which i'm
doing anyways to these other
distributors i said
i'm already they're doing nothing
they're just pushing a button to send
the materials that i've given them
i i have your delivery list and your
specs i make that i do all the delivery
items
please just give me a chance the third
time they did
so now it's direct and if there's
netflix people watching
thank you very much i really appreciate
that you let me have that chance and i
made delivery i made delivery two months
ahead of their delivery schedule
and everything's fine and they already
confirmed delivery
and it's perfect delivery and you know
their delivery schedule is five pages
long
i mean and by the way i have to deliver
those movies in 18 languages
and and six subtitles 20 there's 25
versions of them
and uh i mean delivery alone is a lot
more money than a lot of indie
filmmakers
spend on making their movies just making
delivery all the soundtracks all the m e
tracks
everything i mean it's it's a very very
extensive process making delivery
but there's you know companies you use
who are certified you know
um um i forget what they call them not
aggregators uh
whatever they're they deliver they
specialize in
in delivering to netflix and you hire
them and they do your dubs and you're
this and you're that and you just have
to manage it all
and then you know some stuff you do your
own stuff your own artwork and things
like that
you have making delivery is is a big
part of the business and you have to do
it properly
but i really appreciate that netflix
gave me the chance to do it
and i did it properly and hopefully that
you know i mean i again that's part of
distribution
how did you get the appointment to to
pitch to even know that your pitch was
too long originally
and you shortened it down because at
heart i'm a sales guy
i mean you know i remember i went from
law school into the sales department of
a distribution company
that's what you do you you get
appointments and you meet with people
and you pitch
them and you have to be super super
tenacious
and and very persistent and polite
and the most important thing is you have
to
here's here's the motto i tell everybody
who works for me
you can quote me on this no means not
today
everybody starts with a no everybody
starts with a no and if you take
no as the definitive answer you cannot
survive in this business
i say no means not today it means i'm
not going to give you the
appointment today i'm not going to give
you the deal i'm not going to give you
i'm not going to even talk to you i'm
not going to return your email
i don't take that as personal rejection
that's part of the business
it's a pain in the butt but it's part of
the business and i just keep
at it over and over and over in a very
nice way
i assume that that's part of the
business and
i have 22 years of experience getting
those
there's lots and lots of no's lots of
doors shut on your face lots of
no return phone call thousands tens of
thousands of them
but you know ultimately if you believe
in your product
and you know that you have something to
offer to them you know sooner or later
they'll maybe you know give you a shot
i used to say you know it takes a
hundred calls to get an appointment
i don't say that anymore now i say it
takes 250 calls to get an appointment
the number's gone up so if you know that
going into it
and you know for all the people who were
upwards with me in my office
they know that that's true they might
say no jeff you're wrong it's now 300.
you know and but we you know that that's
part of the process
and and you just deal with it and you
live with it and it's it's it's
is it a little depressing and
aggravating yeah of course it is
you know and are people totally rude and
you know not returning any emails or
calls right
it's part of the process
and when you went in the third time to
pitch
what are you bringing with you just a
log line synopsis
okay i'm an anomaly don't
independent producers who are watching
this do not assume this is this is this
is the blair witch project this is
this is not what normally goes on okay i
had a track record from two other films
if i didn't have that i wasn't even
gonna get every single time you do it
it's a new adventure
yeah so they know that i can make the
movie on time and on budget on a quality
movie
that helps open the door and get the
appointment to start with
all right secondly um
everything got delivered on time and
thirdly they did well with the movies
had they not done well i wasn't going to
get another appointment
it's business it's all statistics they
look at their little
ipad in front of you and they say okay
your numbers are they don't tell you the
numbers
because that's you know confidential um
but if your numbers aren't good you're
one you're not getting an appointment
and two you're not getting a deal
so so how do you here's the big question
so how does a new filmmaker
even get the first appointment how do
you get the first time in there
here's how i think you get it in you got
to go in with somebody else
you got to go in with an established
producer who has a track
record who you can make believe in you
or who does believe in you
and can hold your hand through the
process and give you that credibility
and that experience
because not only what the streamers want
and the broadcasters but
your investors the investors want they
want to know
that you're going to be able to deliver
what you say you can deliver and if you
haven't done it before it doesn't mean
you can't do it you probably can do it
it just means they don't know for sure
that you're going to be
and so they want to bet on somebody
who's done it before
so for say a streamer to you know
say okay you know jeff will make sure
your products going to get delivered on
time and on budget equality
or an investor i guess i have a track
record
that helps it really helps to have a
track record and that's sort of what all
the agencies have and all you know
these are the people want to do business
with people that they've already done
business before because it's more
predictable so
getting in the first one or two times is
way more difficult
because you don't have a track record so
i think the best way to do that is to
hook up with somebody who does
unless you can get super lucky and you
know get your own appointment
and where would one meet a person of
this caliber yeah that's the problem
i mean generally you're going to go on
the internet and you're going to watch
all these
webcasts and interviews and all this
kind of stuff and all these people who
are claimed to be you know
teachers and master classes and this and
that and
and pros and it's tricky it's tricky i
mean but you kind of opened it up for me
to do a pitch for myself here
i mean i do consulting for those
people to find other people so i don't
necessarily do that for people
i have done it i have done a couple of
projects where i've i've
mentored them once in a while i'll do
that but
usually what i do is as a consultant i
hire myself
as a consultant to hook those people up
with other like
people either certain genres because
by the way like when you're dealing with
netflix now there are
i don't know there's got to be a thou i
don't know 500 to a thousand buyers i
mean there's
so many departments now with so many
little niches
so if you fit into this category like if
you're horror
psychological thriller blah blah blah
blah blah there's like maybe five
different categories and you need to go
into the right one
so you got to be hooked up with somebody
who kind of knows how to navigate that
one
it's a little tricky these days okay
here's another question
so i'm at an event let's say and
it's it's maybe film oriented
and maybe it's afm whatever
how am i approaching someone i see them
from across the room i realize you know
what this person
could get me in that door yeah how am i
approaching them where i'm not
disingenuous how i'm not
this sleazy la sort of opportunist
or maybe all the rules go out the window
great great question and and it really
boils down to
how do you do it in a bar i mean you
know like it just depends on who you are
what mood you're in how many drinks
you've had you know it really does it's
it's a chemistry thing okay sure yeah
you know it's true like sometimes you
just feel a little more
daring sure um you don't want to be that
sleazy la type of thing
nobody wants that but you know sometimes
people
respect and you know it could be like i
don't know how to do
i was never great in a bar ironically
i'm pretty good in a sales room but like
i'm not
that good in a bar um i just don't feel
comfortable in that environment
i hear you and it's the same standing in
the lobby at the afm and the lowe's
hotel there it's
it's tricky it's really trick and
they're usually talking to people they
always look so busy
you don't want to interrupt um so
[Music]
that's got nothing to do with filmmaking
and everything to do with interpersonal
skills and and confidence and
and humility and whatever it's it's
chemistry
yeah i think that's a fair answer you're
right and and there are people that are
masters at it
i see them at starbucks i see them
wherever and they're just
they just have that it factor where they
can start conversations
yeah and it's not over the top i need
something from you
right and then there's other people and
i and i can't even say that they're
trying to be sleazy or disingenuous
it's just it's just an approach yeah and
i think some people just
you're right i don't really feel
comfortable in bars either so i get
it's a it's it's a it's a chemistry
thing yeah so i know that's the word i
use
yeah that's a good point and i don't
know if
chemistry i guess can be manipulated i
don't know
yeah yeah i mean it's also you know it's
funny that all these markets
and festivals have these big parties
right the problem with the parties is
they're so loud you can't really talk to
anybody you can't engage but maybe
that's better
you know you can i don't know it's it's
a social dynamic that it's it's tricky
you know i generally approach it as real
business like that's who i am just
a real straight-up business guy which
isn't
sometimes that doesn't work a lot of
people want it to be more social
and i you know yeah but then sometimes
the ones that are really good at that
it's it's like a flakiness
so there's a really fine line to it yeah
i don't think it depends on
the other person right how they receive
that some people like to be
you know have that flaky thing some
people don't but you don't know
because you're another person so you
have no idea right it's like blind
dating
yeah no that's that's true good point
have you only pitched
netflix three times and you're
successful at all pitches or
there were more times there were more
times yeah
i forgot to mention that yeah there were
many more times when they
they were not as receptive which is fair
game right
you can't like everything but it taught
you something
i know it's a cliche but you learned
shorten the pitch maybe
what they like no it's not they they
didn't like it they didn't like what i
had to offer so far is very
you know you can't expect everybody to
like everything
okay i mean you know i respectfully
disagree i think the other stuff i
pitched was
some ways even better but didn't happen
that time
but my motto is no means not today so
those are on the back burner
there will be another cycle i will pitch
them again i have to wait for new people
to come in
sometimes or you know people to change
departments or whatever and then you
know you
do it again are you bringing in art
like key art as well or no that doesn't
factor in
oh yeah yeah i mean yeah especially at a
streaming company
um yeah at a distributor you don't have
to because the distributor wants to make
the key art
so they they actually don't want you
they want to do it okay unless you've
had it done professionally really good
and you're a good artist whatever um i
always bring in key art
one little you know to get it's it gives
a visual image
and i and i bring in a trailer and key
art and
a log line that's it that's all you need
it's pretty short and sweet
and so then how does it go okay great
they tell you right there
no we can't do this they say we'll let
you know yeah
they said we'll let you know it's a it's
a
but you can after you leave those
meetings
you analyze that we'll let you know for
a long time
was it a good we'll let you know was it
a medium one was a bad one
like you know was there an inflection it
was a reflection
sure and then you just hope that on your
follow-up you know you get a good result
and then do you do you so that what's
your time frame for
following up i usually ask them when i
should follow up
you know i actually i used to ask now i
say i'll follow up with you in a week
is that okay um so
because you don't want to appear that
you're bugging them or pestering them or
whatever
and so you do and you got to be good at
follow-up and then uh
you know hopefully you get a response if
you don't you politely follow up you
know a couple days later
everything's going to be polite and
professional even though
they're not necessarily i'm not saying
netflix i'm netflix netflix is actually
the most professional show
i've ever done absolutely no i'm not
saying that for the video it's true
yeah they their follow-up is
unbelievable they return their call for
me anyways i've been lucky that
my buyer has been super super responsive
and polite
and professional whereas some people
you'll never hear
anything from them distributors
primarily you wonder if your email's
even working
you didn't get a bounce back but like
you often wonder
you know so you follow up politely be as
professional as possible
and you know just sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't
how much money can i expect to get if i
sell my film with netflix
i mean great question i think it's
very individual based on you know your
film
what the buyer wants to pay so everybody
wants a range
and by the way most indie producers
usually lie about this in cocktail
parties they throw
numbers get thrown around it's it's
often not the case
the truth is this okay first of all i
don't feel comfortable necessarily
talking about that in the interview but
secondly um in in my netflix contracts
it says that i'm not supposed to talk
about it because
they don't want other indie producers
saying hey you gave him that much
they don't want to have to compete back
and forth or whatever so
i'm going to be respectful of that it's
it's an actual clause in the contract
okay
that's fair absolutely isn't it damaging
for a filmmaker to think of their movie
as a product
i guess as an artist you might wanna
you might think that that's a little
insulting or belittling maybe as an
artist but
depends what you consider a product to
be i mean if we look up the definition
of a product it's
you know something that gets consumed i
think you know or something like that i
don't know if i haven't looked it up but
i assume it would be like something like
that
um so you want your movie to be watched
that's consumption by viewers
so in that case it is a product i mean
you know
it's an entertainment product but that's
semantics
so we don't have to call it a product we
can call it a movie
when do you think we started thinking
about movies as products or has it
always been that way going back to
kubrick and and even farther back
remember i didn't go to film school so
in
in in you know in a commerce program and
a law program
everything's a product or a service i
mean that's the terminology you're using
right so that's just the terminology
that i'm used to using
but i'm sure they don't use that
terminology in film school
they call it you know film or movies or
something like that i don't think they
call them products
so it's just re it is semantics it's
it's the same
item it's just what you're calling it i
don't i don't mean to belittle a film by
calling it a product like it seems to me
like you're almost suggesting that i am
belittling it
by using the term product i you know
there's lots of
things everything's a product or a
service
so i it's i'm not degrading the film by
calling it a product
okay so i guess because for me i think
of a product as a widget
and i think of it as serving some type
of a function
in the home or or in the car whatever
but then a film or a book
or music to me
i guess it is a pro i just don't i don't
see it in that way and i'm just
wondering if if other people
will will either agree or disagree and
okay so
in in classic business school
there's products and services so a
product would be a widget like you
described
and a service would be you know like
legal services or
okay what would a film be does it fall
into either category or is it it's got
its own category
i guess it would fall into a category
but but for me i guess it's just
something that i
i take in and i'm not really expecting
a certain result from but maybe that's
too ethereal i guess
yeah i mean perhaps there is another
category
i mean you know perhaps i missed that in
you know one of my marketing classes or
something like that maybe there's a
third category
that it you know is a consumable or
something sure
something like that but uh i i
really don't feel that it's a derogatory
term to call a film
a product and by the way when when they
when they were being sold in dvds like
when you bought a dvd
is that a is that also not a product or
no you're correct like what about a
hardcover book
i mean now everything's digital right so
you're not receiving anything but uh
but a book is something you touch
and you put on a shelf very good point
yeah i guess it's just training my mind
to think that way and and maybe that's
the difference between
an artist that's successful and one
that's not is just knowing that
even though this is your sort of blood
sweat and tears and you may or may not
be writing for a so-called market
that it is a product and maybe that's
what separates people
it's just it's terminology like in a
distribution company or even in say a
streaming company
what would or studio the collection
of movies that they have do you know
what term they use for that
no inventory okay okay now inventory is
a product term
got it it's it's that's how much stuff
we have in our warehouse on how many
widgets we have in our warehouse on our
shelves
that's inventory so having film rights
that's your inventory or your catalog
that would be your catalog
um but that's inventory basically okay
that makes sense so the amazon warehouse
is going to have x number of boxes of
oatmeal
and i'm going to place an order for one
well okay let me let me rephrase that
okay
dvds sitting on a shelf would be
inventory because those are those are
physical tactile
objects right the rights to the films
would be a catalog
or a library so it wouldn't there's it's
not necessarily inventory it's it's a
catalog or library because it's rights
but now when you're delivering those
rights
it's interesting you know maybe there
should be new terminology because when
you're delivering them
not phys like digitally where there is
no physical tactile medium that you're
actually touching
[Music]
maybe there should be another word maybe
it's not product but i don't know the
other words so
probably somebody's maybe one of your
viewers will phone in and say hey you
should use that word
and let me know please okay i know
you've said previously that you
you love movies and you've talked about
how you know stories are very dear to
your heart
but that you went into this business to
make money
is there anything wrong with that why
does that get a negative connotation
negative negative spin it doesn't have a
negative spin to me
i mean why does anybody go into business
i mean you know
it depends on the business you go into
like luckily i went into a business that
i really enjoy
and that i and there's an artistic
element and a creative element which
makes the business more fun and more
exciting
but i do want to live a nice comfortable
life and
i want my family to be comfortable so
making money is an important component
of that i mean it's
kind of finding a balance in your life
um
but let me readily admit this to you
okay if you want something evil you know
if i didn't think there was an
opportunity to make money in the film
business then i wouldn't have gone into
it
okay as much as i would have i would
have made films
but i would have been a hobby filmmaker
as opposed to a career filmmaker
and i would have you know maybe been a
practicing lawyer and hopefully made
you know nice living which would afford
me the opportunity
to hire people to make that movie for me
so i could have done it that way
but i did see that there was an
opportunity early on to do to make a
living at the film industry
so i stayed with it because
because i was able to do that now if i
would advise people that if they want to
have a nice balanced comfortable life
if they don't feel that they can make a
living at it then it doesn't mean you
can't make movies it just means maybe
don't make a living
at that do something else that you can
make a living at
and you know same thing i would say to
actors
if you're not making a living at being
an actor doesn't mean you have to quit
acting
it means go get a job that you can
support yourself and have a balanced
life
but still stick to the acting and
hopefully you get a lucky gig here or
there
and i know they say to me well you have
to be full time and committed to it in
order to you know take it seriously
and i say yeah but you know that's about
finding a balance
whatever balance works for you in your
life so just find that and be
comfortable with it
but you know i would put my family above
filmmaking
so the comfort of my family would if i
had to sacrifice and never make another
movie
because i wanted my family to be
comfortable it would be a no-brainer
in a second that would be the decision
and that's the balance that i have in my
life
sure and that's a fair response what if
someone says well i'm a filmmaker but
i'm not good at contract law
i'm not good at details like that i'm
more of a visual person i'm not
analytical it's funny when you say what
if
you just described every filmmaker
that's not a what if
that's every single filmmaker every
filmmaker is looked at
i get you i get the fact that you think
we have to know business aspects and all
this kind of stuff but
that's not what we signed up for it's
not who we are i'm creative
i i need to express my artistic self i
i i don't even enjoy the other stuff
it's a necessary evil of the business
what you do is evil what i do is
artistic and fun
and i say okay fair enough but if guys
like me don't do what we do
then guys like you don't do what you do
here's the analogy i use
drive into universal studios through the
lankersham boulevard entrance
okay not through the other side the
lancashire boulevard stuff when you
drive in there you need to pass by that
big
38 story black building there on the
right or whatever that you know that big
nbc universal building okay everybody
drives right past it
and they they can't wait to get into the
studio and go to the back lot and see
the tour and all the fun stuff oh here's
the sound stages here's where the movies
have been made here's
this that all the fun stuff do you know
what goes on in that building
that's all the finance distribution all
the sales and marketing
to enable the rest of the stuff that
goes on on that tour to happen
you take down the functions of that
building and you don't have a studio
anymore
so yeah is it boring is it finance and
numbers and
sales and all that stuff that's not
artistic yeah it's
but that's the heartbeat of the
operation that's what makes it tick
because last time i checked they called
the film
business the film business they don't
call it the film
art the film they call it the film
business
so the word film and the word business
are equal yeah the word film came first
but you could call it the business of
film if you want those are equal
components
they need each other you need good
artistic
entertainment in order to drive a
business but you need a business in
order to facilitate
the artistic endeavor that's a marriage
they're both important
so do people like what i do no no film
listen let me make this very clear i
want to make this super clear
if i never had to look at another
contract negotiate another deal
look at another spreadsheet make another
phone call
ever in my life i wouldn't miss it for a
second if i could do
nothing but write and direct for the
rest of my life i would be the happiest
guy you ever met happier than any of
these other filmmakers
i would love that what a luxury that
would be
i wouldn't miss any of that other stuff
you think i enjoy it it is a necessary
evil
okay but it just it's part of it it's
like saying
have a body you know you can have a
heart but not a brain you can't the two
work hand in hand you have to have both
can you share about the netflix deal
that you got what are some of the
components of it
i'll explain how netflix deals work so
there's generally two types of netflix
deals there's hybrids in between but the
two major categories
are what they call netflix branded
or netflix originals so when you watch
netflix and
and it says a netflix original it means
that they created that product
okay product i shouldn't use they
created that movie or that tv series
all right it was an in-house production
which they funded and they own
and it's it's a that's why they call it
the netflix original
all right they didn't necessarily make
it they might have hired a third-party
production company they don't have
necessarily an in-house production
company so
they they financed it and they own it
but they could have hired
other people to actually make it for
them that's often the case
and so we call those service producers
those are people who take on a contract
to make something for netflix and all
the other streaming services
so that's one side all right the other
side is
an independent production company or
studio
will make something finish it complete
it
and then then netflix will acquire it
finished
and that's the non-branded side all
right so those aren't netflix originals
because they didn't make them
so on when my so that's what i do i make
my movies and then they acquire them
the hybrid would be sometimes netflix
will say
hey do you want to make a movie if
if if you make this movie we will
acquire it
so they might say to you beforehand and
it's very rare they say that by the way
it used to be used to be more common
it's rarer now
um where they would say it's not a
pre-sale per se
okay because a pre-sale means that
they're generally they're going to pay
for it up front
so they'll say they'll give you a
pre-commitment and say if you make this
and it
you know it's within our standards and
everything that you do and we trust
you're going to make it properly
then we will acquire it from you for
this amount of money
so that's the hybrid situation
and so i mean listen most people who are
going to do work for netflix are going
to work on the branded side
and that's where most of the activity
comes because most of what they do now
is
is their own stuff you know they become
a huge studio right
so they hire lots and lots of outside
production people
and you know like all young people who
are graduating from film school
hopefully they can work on that side
because there's lots of jobs there
there's tons of activity tons of
production going on
but they own it all and on my side
which is fewer and fewer and fewer
acquisitions um you know
we are independent producers we own it
um it's harder to do this because you
got to self-finance it there's cash flow
issues
there's you know lots and lots of
logistics that you have to go through
here it's easy
hey guys you're going to make this movie
for us don't worry about any of the
financing or marketing we got it all
covered just make us a really really
good movie or tv show
which is the dream what we were talking
about before
so i've considered that site too but
that you got to get on a list there
i mean that's that's what we call
curated i mean it's not like hey you
show up and you say hey guys i'm
available what show you're going to put
me on
no no it's like it's not actually we
have a list of five
ten thousand filmmakers and we have one
film that needs to get made who we gonna
choose you know
what's the best way for a filmmaker to
generate revenue for themselves
indeed it's the indie business is a
tough tough business
don't get me wrong it is a super super
tough business and and it's not getting
any easier
so for an independent filmmaker i mean
listen probably the safest way to do it
is to actually work for somebody else
you know to work on like you know if you
could get hired on a like a netflix
production or something like that
um and make a living that that's a good
way to do it but you're not making your
own stuff you're not choosing what
you're gonna make
so if you wanna go down that indie route
where you're going to choose it
and and and direct it and decide
you know how everything you want to be
in the driver's seat
it's tough to make money it's a tough
tough business
and and i feel it's it's a lot tougher
now than when i started in it
and everybody says yeah but there's so
much more being consumed and so many
more outlets and so many more streaming
companies and
and now it's the world is the whole
marketplace because it's digital
and that's true well that's true the
problem is
nobody wants to pay for anything
everybody's so used to consuming
everything for free
i mean look at all the apps on your
phone how many apps do you pay for
i mean think of the apps that you have
like the val like waze
or or google i mean you know google's
going through a suit now but i mean i
mean think of the
the power of the compute that you have
in the palm of your hand
for nothing for free yeah you're paying
for your sell signal
but i mean so it's the same with movies
and music music's
even worse i mean everybody and
especially the younger generation
they're so used to not paying for
anything nobody wants to pay for
anything
like i never it never occurred to me
when i used to go to the movies and pay
you know
fifteen dollars for for my ticket and
and twelve dollars for popcorn and a
drink
that was a nice night out and i enjoyed
it i mean
you talked to young people about that
are you crazy why would i do that when i
can download it for free on my phone
you know so the problem with the
industry and with a lot of artistic
industries right now
is that in a lot of you know technology
based industries i mean you know
computer software being probably the
leading one is that it gets pirated so
much
and that really nobody wants to pay for
anything
so it's really really hard to monetize
stuff now
you put it out there and hopefully
people respond to it and love it but
even then they don't want to pay for it
yeah and one of the things that was so
enjoyable about going to the movies in
the past
was that people didn't have a phone that
it's very distracting to be around it
yeah i mean that's
that's another discussion that's the
distraction discussion but the
the the monetizing discussion sure you
know even
nobody ever blinked an eye going into a
blockbuster store and renting a title or
buying a dvd nobody blinked
today it's unheard of to like
you know and i say to my kids you know
it's gonna cost us 4.99 to stream this
movie tonight
are you kidding me i'll just download it
for free
i mean my sons know my son's every kid
every kid knows how to navigate the
internet so well you can get anything
anything you want do you think it hurts
that there's too much
choice i know that sounds like a really
weird no i
i call it i don't i call it dilution
there's too much delusion
i mean it's just there's so much
available now
um i mean just look at youtube the
amount of
content available on youtube it's 500
lifetimes worth of content
if if not more and get and growing every
day by you know an
extra 10 lifetimes every single day
um it's just it's so
we're bombarded by so much here's his
one of my friends
said it to me he said the good news
about you know the worldwide you know
digital economy and
the internet is that you have access to
the whole world
the bad news is you can't get anybody's
attention anymore
because it's so diluted there's so much
out there so i do think
it's great to have choice obviously but
look at i mean i i don't you know i
don't want to give my age away but i
grew up we had
i think we had eight or ten channels on
our tv
well i have 600 channels now i mean i
don't even
get past the first hunt you know i used
to have my favorites like everybody else
but like i mean
how could you ever consume even a
fraction i don't even know what's going
on you know
i mean let alone all the digital stuff
you know like i mean you're just
bombarded by it
and i wonder if it would deepen the
experience of having less experience
other than having less
variety just because then you're able to
say okay this this is it
this is in my niche i don't have to
worry about something where there's 20
more sort of like it
well that's why marketing is so
important and that's why the big
companies have an advantage because they
have the funds to spend
to create the awareness so the
difference between you know one thing
and another thing is that you know about
this because you were advertised
or you were made aware through some very
expensive advertising campaign
so some indie film might be equally as
good as a studio film but nobody's ever
going to know about it
that's the difference so and that's why
you know a lot of services
are still driven by advertising because
i guess it works
right people still you know
get affected by that yeah well in the
pandemic during you know
i mean normally you would go to an art
house theater and you would see
different things on the marquee
that you could look up and say okay this
looks like a good one now it's great
because these independent film trailers
they'll suggest a similar one and so
there's films that
i see from a couple years ago that had
no idea existed
that maybe they didn't make it to the
front page of netflix so so let me ask
you this so are you
happy i mean what they're doing
basically you know is youtube let's say
let's
use youtube as an example you know we
can use any of these digital sites
um is profiling you sure and i realize
that yeah i have a footprint yeah but
you're happy with that because now
they're recommending stuff to you that
you wouldn't otherwise know about that
i'm happy with that part yeah yeah so am
i yeah i actually have too right
people say oh your privacy is being
invaded and everything like that i say
yeah it is but you know what
yeah they're actually doing me a favor
and they're showing me things that i
wouldn't otherwise discover
sure yeah they know they know that i'm
going to like certain things and yeah
now i get these ads for different things
that it's like oh wow okay yeah i guess
i guess i am in that demographic but
yeah the
the the movies that that the the
creative stuff i like
so do i yeah and you know you're gonna
get bombarded with a lot of ads and
stuff like that and you know and
they're gonna try to move you
psychologically in a different direction
we
all know about that stuff which is not
great but there is the
the flip side where you know you are
creating they're creating some
convenience for you
yeah and i do like that part and and
there's some great indie trailers and
sometimes it's fun to just spend a night
just watching a bunch of indie trailers
like going down that rabbit hole one to
the next to the next and yeah you'd
never get there otherwise
no no and you and you couldn't get and i
did enjoy going to blockbuster
and trying to find some obscure film i
didn't want the ones that were there
were 20 of them on one wall yeah
but but this this there's more discovery
here
yeah well that's like an offense like
walking down the back aisles of the
blockbuster store seeing all the titles
you've never looked at picking them up
now you just do it digitally
sure and not only that you don't even
have to move because they put it all in
front of you one after the other they
serve it up to you
should a filmmaker sell their movie or
license their movie
do you know the difference legally
should i explain that would you
yes i would okay 99.9
of the time it's a license this is the
legal terminology okay i use the terms
sell very loosely and a lot of people do
but the legal terminology of a sale
means
that you were actually giving up the
copyright the ownership of the movie
so it used to be called a negative
pickup where you would pick up the
asset of the film you're taking the
asset
the ownership of the asset which a lot
of people refer to as the copyright
which is the ownership of the asset
and you're giving it to somebody else
and they're paying you for it
so now you don't have any ownership of
it anymore that's a sale
it's super rare that that had a lot
studios when they sell their library
their catalog you know their company
that's sale right 99
of the time you're doing a license where
what you're saying is
here's my asset you can
borrow it for this period of time for
this amount of money and then when that
expires you give it back to me
that's a license and then you know
you're not really giving them the asset
you're letting them
use that for their viewers so it's like
renting a house versus selling it
in some sense and so eventually the
rights are going to revert back to the
owner that's good once you're leasing
this
it's a little different the rights never
revert i mean
all you're doing you always own the
movie on a license
you're just giving them okay there's
rights you're giving them the right to
to to um expose the movie to their
customer base
or you know in some cases let's say
let's let's go with an extreme example
where
you're licensing it to say back then in
the dv in the product side of the
business
to a dvd you know to a distribution
company
and they're going to make dvds so you're
giving them the right to make
put your movie on a dvd disc and sell it
to you know walmart who will sell it to
the world
right and that right the consumer when
they buy it will always get to own
that right to watch your movie on that
disc
but they don't have the right to sell it
to anybody else to replicate the disc
to air in a movie theater and they only
have the right to
own that and watch it when they want to
watch it that's the extent of the
license agreement
and then when the period runs out from
the distributor
they can't make any more dvds they give
it back to you okay now in the case of
digital distribution
they have the right to say send out a
streaming link or you know or put it
onto a streaming platform you know or
like
itunes or netflix or something like that
for a certain period of time when it
expires
they lose that right and but there's
never transfer of ownership
only in a sale that's the difference
between
sale and license is ownership it speaks
to ownership
and and before streaming services did a
lot of filmmakers used to sell
their films let's say when the vhs
market or even uh remember video discs
were filmmakers selling or licensing was
it the same thing back then
hopefully they were licensing it's not a
good practice to sell
your rights like to sell your your asset
there's no reason you need to
i mean generally if somebody wants to
own it you can just make a long
licensing deal
like 25 years or some crazy thing like
that you know or 50 years or or what
or there are licensing deals a lot of
them called in perpetuity
meaning forever so they actually never
buy the asset
but they have the right to to exploit it
forever so they might as well own it but
it's just easier to just do the license
deal
can any movie get the attention of a
distributor or are distributors only
looking for certain kinds of movies
it's not certain kinds of movies it's at
certain quality levels
certain budget levels i mean generally
shorts aren't going to get the time of
day from a distributor because it's hard
to monetize them
anything less than a feature is probably
not going to be handled by a distributor
because
they don't have any place to sell it
they're just looking for stuff they can
sell something that is you know
commercially viable
so if they don't think it's commercially
viable they're not going to look at it
and generally anything shorter than a
feature is is being tough to sell
it's not really a market for short i
mean there's a viewing market for it but
not a not a consuming like not a
purchasing market
so when you say a certain quality
is a distributor wanting to know the
budget of something before they'll even
look at the trailer no
they want to know the quality the budget
is in some ways inconsequential that
could be a
some really really talented filmmakers
can make fantastic films on
super low budgets some unso
you know not so good filmmakers spend a
fortune to make crappy films
it's about the quality of film okay
everybody lies about the budget anyway
so you never know what's real
um the only thing you know is you watch
the movie and you say hey this looks
really good
and who cares what they made it for
honestly who really cares
as long as it's entertaining so the two
things people lie about in hollywood
budget and their age
i know but the interesting thing is they
go high on the budget and low on the age
how many times do you see filmmakers
make a film
with zero attention to their
distribution plan
most of the time almost all of the time
actually
yeah i mean that's most of what
i consult on i mean almost
all my consulting is let's talk about
how you're going to sell the movie
and hopefully they call me to consult
before they make the movie
and you know people say like why are we
talking about this and i said because
the first question asked is do you want
to make money with your movie do you
have an intention to sell your movie for
money
if they say no then i said you know we
don't have to have this conversation we
can just talk about artistic stuff if
you want
but if the answer is yes then then we
talk about marketing and distribution
long before we talk about production and
most filmmakers don't talk about it
for two reasons one three reasons one is
they don't think to talk about it you
know they don't really know
that that's a question that you have to
ask before the fact
two is they can't stand the whole
distribution business i mean it's just
such a turn off you know because it's
not what they do they make movies they
don't sell movies you know and three is
it's you know it's something it's almost
denial because
like i said you got to spend a lot of
money on marketing and it's a whole
business and everything like that and
that might you know destroy the whole
project if i said hey
go raise as much money for marketing as
you are for production
that's like a non-starter but it
shouldn't be
because that's the business do most
people contact you
after the fact after they've tried to
get this film out
you know they've already had their party
they've already had their festivals run
yeah that yes they do and that's because
they didn't know to contact me before
now
a lot a lot of the newer clients are
starting to
contact me first because they're
watching some of my videos and and some
of my materials and stuff
and a lot of people on the internet are
talking about that but not
not too many people are doing it they're
just going through the motions and
talking about it because
how many indie filmmakers you know who
actually started their career in
distribution
because like like i said it's crazy to
go from
distribution to production i mean i can
see going the other way around
i mean it's crazy it's just you know
it's very rare that that would happen
so it's kind of unique that i would
understand distribution and have a
really soft spot for
indie filmmakers because i am one of
them and
like the thing one of the things i enjoy
the most
is almost like and this maybe is the
legal part of me kicking in
is i love to defend an indie filmmaker
in a distribution negotiation
i love that it's my favorite thing i
love to sit beside them
and listen to the distributor explain
how the deal is going to work
and then kind of pull them aside and
explain how the deal really works
and what really is going to go on and
then sometimes they'll say okay jeff you
say it because i won't say it properly
or sometimes i won't even be in the room
to call me or whatever or they'll send
me their contract or deal memo
and then i love to renegotiate the deal
and say
okay how about this let me give you a
perfect example okay
so every distributor if you've ever been
in one of these distributions you're an
indie filmmaker just made
a feature it's a good feature you know
it's a good feature
and you want to make money with it so
you're going to go you get lucky you get
into you know
say five distribution meetings with
reputable distributors all right don't
ask
how they got there you do it okay you
get into the first meeting here's how it
goes
and i'm gonna shorten this okay it's a
lot longer you know pleasantries how are
you that it's
a great film okay all right we're going
to make you a great offer
all right we're going to give you it's
going to be a 10-year
deal exclusively and
we're going to give you 200 000 minimum
guarantee
up front against um we're going to take
a 30
fee and 10 costs no they're sorry they
don't say
costs we're going to take a 30 fleet
plus our costs
and we're going to give you 200 000 up
front
sound good sounds good i'll take it
really okay now you phone me
now these they they give you the deal
memo they send it to me
i say first question how much did it
cost you to make the movie
eight hundred thousand i said okay
they're giving you two hundred thousand
i know but they're gonna they they also
said they're gonna you know
they're the best in the business and
they're gonna generate two million
dollars in sales
they're going to take 30 so i'm going to
get 70 of 2 million 1.4 million
and they gave me 200 000 up front so i'm
going to get another 1.2 million
so that's a good deal really good i said
okay what if they don't
oh but they said they would okay they
also
here's what i say so i say let me go in
and have a conversation
so i get there and i say okay ari you're
the distributor
are you the best in the business
absolutely we're the best and we've been
at 25 years
we've sold 500 movies we are the best
good because i only want to deal with
the best i don't want to deal with
second-rate guys
i'm glad we're sitting here you're the
best i want to deal with you
you're here you're you're dealing with
the best great okay
what do you think you can sell on the
movie well we told we said we can do two
million dollars in sales and by the way
that's a low estimate we didn't want to
tell them we're probably going to do 5
million
but we want to be conservative because
we don't want to give the filmmakers you
know
like bad expectations but we can do two
until a million dollars in sales
gross sales on this really that's good
and it's likely going to be a lot more
but let's go with that number
i say fantastic you can take a 30 fee so
you're going to deliver
1.4 million dollars back right
you are the best and that's a low
estimate
why'd you only give them 200 000 up
front i got a i got a
this crazy idea you're the best you know
exactly what you're doing
and you're gonna do two million dollars
in sales
with your eyes closed that's going to be
a walk in the park because you're
actually going to do more
you're going to generate 1.4 million how
about this why don't we just split the
difference and give us 700 000 up front
as a minimum guarantee half of what
you're going to do as a no-brainer
and you're the best at it oh no no we
can't do that
why not well what if it doesn't sell of
course it's going to sell you just told
us it's going to sell for 2 million and
you told us you're the best
but what if it doesn't sell but no no
don't but i i don't want to deal with
somebody who's not going to sell it
you're the best that's why i'm here
and the 2 million is nothing like it's
it's a walk in the
those are your words not mine well but
maybe it might not sell well
then i don't want to deal with you
because you're not the best and you're
not telling me the right numbers
that's how a negotiation goes okay so
you're the distributor
what do you do do you give an extra 500
half of what your projection is or do
you
stick to the 200 and walk away from the
deal
you likely stick to the 200 and walk
away from the deal why
because you know you're you're not going
to hit that number
if you knew darn well if you had those
sales in your pocket already
you'd give the 700 000 in a heartbeat
because you've already pre-sold it you
already know what to expect
and if and when you're in that situation
you can get that kind of deal
but most indie filmmakers will never be
in that situation they don't have that
kind of leverage
okay because they're new at the game and
they
one is they don't know what to ask for
so they would never have that kind of
conversation because that would be way
too
you know too aggressive okay then then
you get into costs you said you're going
to take your costs how much your costs
well they're going to be around 10 to 12
percent for what
well we have delivery and all this kind
of stuff i say i need
a delivery schedule i need to know what
it is i want to cap you at 5
no no no no and by the way ten years why
do you need ten years
i mean how long is it gonna take you to
sell you could probably sell in
three years well you know just in case
all these just in cases i just spent
eight hundred thousand dollars making my
movie
i didn't get any just in cases from
anybody why do you need all these just
in cases
now the problem with what i'm telling
you is it's easy for me to say that
because
i did that for a living for i sat on the
other side of the table for 22 years so
i know exactly how that game has played
and everything like that
and i'm being you know a little cocky
about it right
you do that as a filmmaker they'll
escort you out of their office
and never want to do business with you
because
you're pushing them too hard but that's
the way it's supposed to be
that's the true deal and that's the true
way
a negotiation should go in that
situation but they have all the leverage
so they don't go that way unless you got
a really good film
and if you got a really good film then
you need to work it
it just all depends on and do you know
how you know if you have a really good
film
whether they want it or not so you got
to push that envelope a bit
you got to believe in yourself and in
your product and you got to push it
and you can't just take the first deal
they put on the table because it's
usually going to be a crappy deal
and you're going to end up losing a ton
of money because you
in some ways you also have to assume
that you're not going to see another
penny after that minimum guarantee
unless you also build in there's lots of
stuff you have to build in performance
guarantees they have to
performance thresholds they have to hit
certain levels within certain time
frames otherwise that's a breach of the
contract
there's all this stuff they hate me the
distributors hate me because i'm one of
them
they don't even some of these new
distributors they don't even know some
of the questions that i like some of the
terms that i put in i tuck them in and
say like where'd this come from
but you know what you get one shot at it
your filmmaker you put your heart so
this is why
i have a real soft spot for filmmakers
because
i know how much time effort and money
they put into the and the heart and soul
they put into making their film
then they walk into these meetings and
get railroaded
absolutely railroaded just because they
don't know what to ask or how to ask for
it and how to push push the issue
because they're too scared to lose the
deal and so they end up taking a really
really bad deal
and in some ways it's better not to take
any deal and try for the next deal
now will the next deal come along maybe
maybe not but basically what you're
saying
is you've throwing it up in the air and
giving it away and
knowing that you're never gonna like a
bad deal is not
worth taking unless you're totally
totally desperate
and there's no other deal to take then
you can take a bad deal
but when you're first starting out and
you're getting in and you have a good
film
you made a good film work it
anyways listen easier said than done i
feel super confident working it because
i
i know all the terms i know all this you
know what i got a better idea
call me and i'll work it for you okay i
will work the deal for you
that's what i like to do like as i said
one of my favorite things
is helping a inexperienced
really good artistic but inexperienced
filmmaker in terms of distribution
negotiate a deal i like doing that
you said performance guarantee that they
have
i know you said a minimum guarantee
which is called an mg nmg
mg performance guarantee what does that
entail
okay it's something i think i made up to
be honest with you
i made it up many years ago i gave it a
name
but people do it but but i do it a lot
um first of all let's let me just define
minimum guarantee so everybody
understands
so you're going to get say 70 of the
revenue which maybe we can negotiate
down to
or up to 75 percent that's called
royalties
or producer share some people in a
production in a distribution call it
could produce your share
or royalties okay that's what you're
going to get that's the producers
take revenue and then a minimum
guarantee or an mg
is what they will give you up front
against that so if you're going to get
1.4 million
total and they gave you 200 000 that was
your minimum guarantee
so now they're only going to give you
another 1.2 the first 200 000
that they earned they've already paid
you up front that's a minimum guarantee
okay a performance guarantee or
performance
threshold so i built these into my
contracts years ago
i'm giving away a really good trade
secret here so everybody pay attention
when i say this
all right you want to deal with a good
reputable distributor and as i said i
just played the game you're the best
right
if you're the best how long is it going
to take you to generate that million
dollars in sale
it's you say it's going to take you two
years
and i'm going to say why is it going to
take you so long you're in every market
you know every customer
you can make phone calls well it's
probably going to take a year but we
need to
have two years say how about this i'll
give you 18 months
and if you don't have seven hundred
thousand dollars of
gross sales contracted and i get to see
the contracts you have to share them
with me
by 18 months from now then i have the
option
to terminate the contract we'll consider
that a technical breach and i am it's my
option
to terminate because you are not
performing at the level that you just
promised me you would perform at
that's what i call performance threshold
and i i built those in and a lot of
distributors say sorry no deal
because they're not confident they don't
want to be held to that
and i say you want my film that's i
expect you
to be able to do what you say you're
going to do and that's my
guarantee that you'll that's my out if
you don't do it i'm not saying i'm going
to necessarily exercise it's an option
so it's my option not yours i have an
exclusive option
to walk away from the deal and and at
that point
there's termination you know language
okay i get this you get this you know
we you know this is how it all resolves
itself
and how if they agreed to that term how
would i know
could i call up and and it would be they
have to part of that term is
they have to give you transparency and
visibility to the deals they've done
which they're supposed to do anyways
that's called reporting
you're supposed to have that because
they're reporting to you
and on a new distribution contract
they're supposed to report to
they should report to you quarterly
every three months for the first two
years you should expect that
so it's not like you're not going to
have visibility to that anyways
it's just what level you're going to hit
in your reporting
this is a serious serious distribution
term that
nobody really does that because they're
too scared to do it or
they haven't thought about it or or
distributors say no way
so most independent filmmakers they
don't want to rock the boat and
they don't know what they don't know
okay most independent filmmakers
they don't even want to get involved in
this this is like doing surgery
you know like uh you know a nurse doing
surgery it's it's
just not what they do they don't want to
do it they don't take a chance they
don't want to get involved and they
can't stand the idea of doing it
okay secondly even if they were to get
involved
they didn't go to medical they didn't go
they didn't learn surgery
so they don't know what to do even if
they have the desire to do it they don't
know what to do
so they don't have the technical
know-how to know what to ask for
and it's not their fault they don't
teach it in film school
the only way to learn that is to
actually be in the in the business and
learn it the hard way
i didn't you know i didn't come into law
school and know that i had to work in
distribution it took me five years to
learn all this stuff
so is it reasonable to expect that a lot
of filmmakers will be taken advantage of
for their first
distribution deal it's not only
reasonable but it's probable
it's it's highly highly likely and it's
and i said on another podcast it's not
that the distributors are evil people
but they they're in business they're in
business to make the best deal that they
can make for themselves
and if the person on the other side
doesn't ask for the right things you
know it's not their
obligation to put it on the table so
they're dealing
it's a little bit of an unfair
negotiation because they have an
advantage of
having more knowledge and more
experience than the person on the other
side
that's why sometimes it's good to go
into these negotiations with somebody
who knows what they're doing like a
lawyer or a consultant or something like
that
because even though you're going to pay
a fee for that you're going to end up
with a much better deal
and you're not going to get screwed so
it's not that they're omitting
information they're just not suggesting
that they're not putting it on the table
okay yeah okay um i mean you know and
in some cases i will say they're
purposely not putting it on the table
because they know they don't have to
they're not being nice about it they're
not being
sympathetic knowing that the guy on the
other side knows nothing
sure they're just so excited most indie
filmmakers are
so excited to just have the the meeting
and then to get any deal that's usually
the case
they're just like just so eager to just
get any deal
which is too bad but it's the nature of
the beast
unfortunately how much time should a
filmmaker expect to put into
distribution
versus pre-production or production
great question so i i
in my world in my experience having made
seven features
takes me about a year to make the movie
by the time i'm i'm talking from idea
to final delivery that's about a year so
there's about a month or two
in idea development stage there's
probably
two to three months in financing there
is
a month or two in pre-production there
is a month or two in production
and then there's you know i didn't do
the math on it probably about six months
in post-production
and delivery so that's the production
phase
distribution minimum
well it's see distribution is not
full-time production what i just
described is full-time
you're maybe not development isn't
full-time where you're working on 100 of
the time but
but production certainly is and
post-production if you're doing your own
edit you know certainly is right
um distribution is full-time
when you're at markets and and when
you're preparing and everything there's
about
i'm gonna say four to five months of
full-time
prep for distribution getting well mind
you if you've done it many times you
have all your lists all together and you
know who your customers are and you're
prepping your materials and
hopefully your trailer is already made
from production i always cut my trailer
first before i cut my movie
and yeah because you need to have a
trailer you change it as you go along
too
but artwork and and whatever
you know presentation materials you want
to have you don't need a ton you just
have some photos and stuff like that
and then you spend you know the first
four to five months putting it out to
the marketplace
perhaps going to a market and we'll talk
about markets versus festivals in a
second
and then you know and soliciting it to
whoever your lists are if oh this is
self-distribution by the way
um if you're doing through a distributor
then you're putting it out to
distributors
and you you want to put it out to you
know i'm going to say 25 to 50
distributors if if you can
that's what seems like a lot but uh you
know when you have your short list of
say top 10
who you really really care about and
then you put it out to all these other
ones and it's not just american if
you're an american producer you don't
just put them out to american
distributors
there's tons of distributors in uk
australia you know who all speak english
and
who do worldwide distribution so the
world is you know
is a big place now and you can deal
pretty well in any country
but then distribution goes on for you
know three to four years
and it goes on your whole life really i
mean as long as you own your film it's
you know as long as your asset
is in existence and you haven't sold it
and it's yours
then you technically can monetize it the
rest of your life
that's what they call library rights i
mean you're just hopefully continuing to
monetize it
it's not as active and robust
generally the second or third time
around you know after
the first year is when most of the sales
happen or the first
yeah the first 12 to 24 months most of
your sales are going to happen
if people want to buy it it's it takes
customers used to take them like three
to four months to make a decision now it
takes them like
six to eight months it's amazing you
think here's a film
watch it do you want it or you don't
want it you think that should take an
evening right
it takes a long time these lead times
are a long time you have to have a lot
of patience
but generally within the first two years
you're going to have exhausted all
or your distributor will have exhausted
all of the sales contacts
and done what i call round one made all
the rounds gotten all the answers back
and you know if it's sold or not
and then after that again it's your
asset and you
it never ends and deliverables are done
by the filmmaker or if you get a
distributor they will do
some of the deliverable work so here's
the thing
the distributor definitely will do the
deliverables but you will pay them to do
the deliverables
everything the distributor does you're
going to pay for and not only will you
pay for the actual
physical deliverable but you will pay a
fee for them to do that
because it costs them time and you know
effort to do it
so for instance let's say let's use dubs
okay let's say you have to do language
dubs
right the distributor themselves aren't
going to make the language dubs they
don't do that they don't have you know
in-house dubbing facilities
maybe one or two do but most of them
don't okay they're gonna go to an
outside third
party dubbing company you know who makes
language versioning and they're going to
hire them
and they're going to tell them exactly
what they need to do and then they're
going to let them do it
and they're going to pay a fee to them
to do it
and the distributor's going to negotiate
that fee and then they're going to
pay the fee to them and then they're
going to charge it back to you
through the revenue that comes back to
your film but in addition to the fee
they paid to the versioning company
they're also going to take a fee for
themselves for managing it maybe
an additional 10 20 so let's say there's
a hundred thousand dollars in language
dubbing
the distributor might add on another you
know fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
in
their labor to manage that process so
the bill you're gonna get
is 120 000 as opposed to a hundred
thousand dollars if you
put it out to the same versioning
company yourself
but if you were to do that then one you
need to know
what versioning companies to go to and
who to ask and make sure you do the
do it the proper way and get the right
companies on board because
you know versioning is a very particular
thing um and two you have to have the
cash flow
because now the version income is going
to charge you a hundred thousand dollars
and you need to pay them a hundred
thousand cash the distributor
has the cash they'll pay the hundred
thousand on your behalf but it'll cost
you an extra twenty thousand but
it's often worth it because you don't
have the cash are some of these bills
from the distributor
set against potential profit or will you
actually get a bill in the mail
that you're like needing to write a
check for so it's
with a good distribution deal everything
should be
recouped against revenue not profit
revenue
so as revenue comes in the way the way
most distribution deals work is
um it's called a waterfall all right so
revenue comes in
so let me use a hundred dollars make it
real simple okay
a hundred dollars comes in the door if
they're working on a thirty percent fee
then the first thirty dollars goes to
them of the hundred
to the distributor all right then
if they have costs of say twenty
twenty dollars then the next twenty
dollars comes off of that to pay for
their costs
all right so now they take that they
recoup their costs so now there's 50
left then if they have given you say a
minimum guarantee
of 10 right then they're going to recoup
that
so they paid you 10 already so they're
going to take the 10 back
so now there's they've taken 60 there's
40 dollars left
and then you're going to get that 40
that's how that works so probably okay
but well yeah
i forgot to say okay now let's say let's
say that
they have costs of seventy dollars
so they took eighty dollars let's say
eighty dollars
so they took third because there was
languaging versioning right
so the 100 came in and
they took thirty dollars as their fee
but their costs were actually
call it ninety dollars they spent to
make some languaging versions
but there's only seventy dollars less so
they take the not they take
the red seventy but you still owe them
twenty dollars they're still out of
pocket twenty dollars
so the question is did they send you a
bill for twenty dollars
and the answer is hopefully not
hopefully they wait until the next
revenue comes in
because that's the way a good
distribution deal should have been
negotiated
but maybe they do i mean filmmakers have
told me they've gotten those kind of
bills
they shouldn't it should be against the
revenue that's coming in
but sometimes they do is there language
that one should look out for to make
sure that it's
set against potential revenue of course
there is a hundred percent there's
language
there's language for everything and you
have to be super particular with your
language
i mean that's that's why you need
somebody who knows what they're doing to
make sure your language is proper and
there and the distributors play games
with the language
all lawyers play games with language
what do you mean by
it purposely confusing people remember
i said it before distributors in
business to make money their job isn't
to rip off the next person but it's to
do the best deal that they possibly can
so you need to make sure that your jobs
do the best deal you can for yourself
just you know you don't know as much as
they do
so make sure you get somebody who does
know so that you can make sure that you
address all those issues to your benefit
or at least
make them fair and so they're not skewed
in their favor
should one be afraid of a short contract
a short term on the contract no just in
terms of like it's only
one page and and really one that's more
elaborate is actually more beneficial no
no
the substantive deal terms depending on
the size of the font can fit onto one
page
oh okay and there's about seven or eight
substantive deal terms and
they generally can fit onto one page i
call those deal memos
or you know i mean that's that's more or
less what we call them deal memos
and often i mean most of my distribution
contracts are only two pages
and then the last paragraph the last
sentence says
um a long form will follow if the you
know
there's an option for the long form to
follow
the long form which you know is 40 to 50
pages is a lot of legal jargon
built up over years and years and years
it's a lot of accounting and
and termination language which is super
important
but often a deal member will say you
know and the rest of the terms per
industry standard for reasonable
industry standard
um then you know sometimes you'll attach
an addendum to it
but you need a deal memo at first the
major
terms are you know how long the deal is
going to be
that's the period or the term the period
right
um what the royalty level is going to be
like what their fees
either what their fee is going to be
what they're going to take or how much
they're going to give you
their costs what their costs are going
to be are they capped
is there i put in a performance
threshold are there performance
thresholds
um what the territory is going to be
like where they're selling it for
what the rights are are you giving them
all the rights or just
certain rights you know just for certain
you know broadcast or
streaming or whatever is it exclusive or
non-exclusive and what the language is
going to be
when you say language mean language of
languages of languages and who's going
to do transcripts or dubbing
no it's just what language rights you're
giving them and then you'll figure that
all out in
costs and everything yeah and then you'd
probably put down okay who's yeah you'd
probably
say who's gonna who's gonna incur this
and
does a distributor um have the right to
change the name of the
like the title of the film if they feel
that in a certain territory
it will do better or they that they have
the right if you give them the right
it's your choice if you want to grant
them that right they'll tell you you
should grant them because they know
better and that will help market the
film better
and in a lot of cases i would agree with
that but they only have the right if you
grant it to them
they don't have any rights other than
what you negotiate
it's all and that's why deal memos are
very long and complicated
because over the years there's been a
lot of stuff negotiated that lawyers
tend to put
in we call those boilerplate clauses
over and over and over
if this happens then that happens then
this happens and you know it depends who
drafted the contract
generally a distributor wants to use a
contract that they drafted
because they trusted and they negotiated
it over the years and they built it over
the years
they're not too receptive for you
bringing in your own distribution
contract
because it won't be as generally as
favorable to them
or they have to spend a lot of time
reviewing it to make sure that it's
fair and the best is you know the
netflix contract
they're i love netflix they're actually
super reasonable believe it or not
they actually care about filmmakers
which you'd be surprised but they do
um but there's no negotiating i mean the
lawyer said to me on the
the business affairs person who's a
lawyer on the other side said um
and you know and i said i'm going to do
my own legals because i'm a lawyer and
i'm
confident that i know what i'm doing um
she said is there anything like
you'd like to address and i said if
there was would it matter
and she said kind of not
what are the top five things a filmmaker
should look for in a distributor
the first one i would say for any
business deal
but it's really really hard to gauge is
honesty
like how do you gauge honesty how'd he
engage that in a partner had to gauge
that in a friend
you know in a in anybody so
it would be great if there was a honesty
test
but honesty is the most important thing
like
trust slash honesty you just want to do
business with people who you can trust
and who you think will be honest with
you so sometimes you would gauge it
through
reputation you might ask other
filmmakers you know
how they did you know like you can say
the distributor who else did you
distribute for
can you give me some references some
other filmmakers of course they'll give
you the ones that went well not the ones
that
were mad at them but you could ask you
can go on a website you know their
website see all the different films
maybe
look up some of the producers of those
other films and you know and email them
or phone and contact them and say hey
did you get a fair deal how did it go
and get it that's how you would gauge
that
but then again that's perspective from
somebody else but at least it gives you
a
sort of a good test um
their business acumen like
do they seem professional does their
website look professional
is did their is their office organized
are they
you know professional getting back to
you on time and communicating with you
um you can sort of tell if if
people are acting professionally or not
and if they're not professional
chances are they're maybe not
professional with their clients
and they're going to be a pain to deal
with so hopefully they don't have to be
the biggest
and most the nicest office they don't
have to have expensive offices in
beverly hills
they just it's got to be seem to be
organized
and they you have to get the impression
that they know what they're doing you
know and that they treat you with some
respect
hopefully even if you're not the biggest
client you know it's
how hard is it to return you know an
email or something like that
what is their breadth their reach into
the marketplace
have they been at it for a while do they
have the customer base that they
actually say
can they get to streamers can they get
to broadcasters
can they get to international
territories do they
really can they really do what they
claim they're gonna do
and so that's also maybe a question you
asked some other filmmakers
or you know maybe you could look them up
you go
it's amazing when you google people you
know and companies what you can find out
i happen it's easier for me because i go
to the markets so like i see if they're
there
i see if they have booths there i see
what their stands look like
i s you know i see them in cocktail
parties and meetings you know
it's it's much easier when you're in the
business to know if they're in the
business
and sort of what their breadth is and
you can also talk to
other people like other producers in
other countries and something like that
and say do you
or other distributors do you know them
have they done business what do you
think
so you can also try to gauge that as
much as possible
um their
their track record on reporting
reporting is a big thing because even if
they're doing the business and they're
not telling you about it
you know it's aggravating i'd say that's
one of the major complaints that just
that indie film producers have with
distributors is they don't report
you never know what's going on and when
they do report it's
usually fabricated you know
so that's the honesty thing we talked
about before um
so you want to see that what the reports
look like that they
you know you want to sort of get some
type of indication that they're
going to be regular and honest with you
and then the last one would be i guess
their distribution deal
what kind of deal they're offering you
know does it feel like it's a fair deal
do they feel like they're trying to hold
you do you feel like you can even make
any money with it
um again they're in business to do the
best deal that they can for themselves
but
did they does it feel like you know you
have a shot with them
and hopefully you need to get some
advice to make sure that you make the
right deal with them because it's not
their responsibility
for you to make the right deal i mean
some people take it upon themselves to
make sure that the deal is totally fair
i mean i have this adage that i always
said i'm really big on fairness fairness
is a huge
theme for me in my life i always say a
good deal
and i learned this on the distribution
side not on the production side
a fair deal not a good deal a good deal
is whatever works for you a fair deal
is one where you sit on this side of the
table and you negotiate and you
you have to come everybody compromises
but you get to something that you're
comfortable with
and then you switch places and on that
side of the table
you're equally comfortable and both
people feel equally compromised
but equally comfortable that's a fair
deal
it's unfair when somebody gets it all
and somebody's left with nothing
and it doesn't have to be equal they
just you just have to feel that it's
fair
how can a filmmaker negotiate a fair
deal with the distributor
well in order to negotiate a fair deal
you got to know what to ask for
i mean if you don't ask for the right
things you're probably not going to get
them
like fair is fair right it's i keep
saying it's not the
distributor's obligation to make sure
you get the fair deal it's your
obligation
so you have to either surround yourself
with people who know what they're doing
or
figure it out yourself know what you're
doing that's any negotiation
you got to know what to ask for or
you're not going to get it
don't assume somebody's going to put it
on the table unless you ask for it
so you know you got to do some homework
where you got to hire somebody to do it
for you
then don't get mad if you got a bad deal
because maybe you didn't ask for the
right things
no you're allowed to get mad everybody
gets mad i mean that's part of
being human um but be mad at yourself
that's who you should need to be mad at
mad at yourself you know it's hard to
get mad at yourself when you
you didn't even know you know how
like it's not like you knew and you left
it out you forgot
you didn't even know so you're mad i
guess at the circumstances
but it's your obligation as a it's your
obligation to your movie
say your movie's like your child and you
want to protect it it's your obligation
to protect your movie
and make sure that you either let
somebody who knows what they're doing do
it for you
or or know what you're doing figure it
out and
don't be don't don't leave yourself
short
so no one's going to come in and say you
know well listen we're not being fair on
our end
really what we should most most
filmmakers get this
even if the filmmaker on the other end
of the table didn't ask for that
if you didn't ask for it kind of like
off
is fair and war and love then it's not
going to happen for you you have to
really know what it is
that you are actually defending against
or trying to get
and they're not going to suggest it for
you listen most distribution agreements
should start off
relatively reasonable
relatively but
they're not always it's your obligation
to make sure that you get it to the
total reasonable and fair place sure i
mean i would think after years and years
and years of doing it that
distributors would hopefully not take
too much advantage but
they do and and it's it's not their
fault
you gotta like it you spend all this
time effort and money
making your movie spend a little bit of
money
getting it represented properly and
distributed properly
it's just as important in some ways it's
more important
how much revenue do you think my movie
can generate is this a smart question
for a filmmaker to ask to a distributor
or will this alienate them
that's a vital question to ask that's
the whole point of the distribution deal
is how much you're gonna
how much money they're gonna generate
you need to ask that question
and you need to hear what they answer
and you need to have them justify why
they answered it
and you know maybe they'll compare it to
other stuff that they've distributed or
other stuff that's been in the
marketplace
that's the essence of the deal it's the
essence of the whole relationship
is how much are they going to generate
it's not all right you nice guys you're
gonna go to film markets and have some
martinis and
and chit chat about my film who cares
about that how much you're gonna make
that's what i really need to know you
need to ask that
and by the way you should probably if
you really want to push the deal and
don't worry about alienating
if you're going to alienate people that
easily don't do business with them
it's all business it's not personal
that's what they do for a living you're
asking them okay
here's what you do for a living can you
tell me what i can expect for you to do
for me
for a living that's not an alienating
question at all
and if you really want to push the
envelope have them put it in writing in
as an addendum here's the fork the
projections that we're projecting now
they're not going to guarantee well
they're guaranteed in a minimum
guarantee
you try to get as much of that like
they'll give you low medium and high
forecasts they'll probably go with the
medium
and you try to get as much of that in a
minimum guarantee as possible
that's the secret but beyond the minimum
guarantee
probably can't give you an absolute
number
and if they did would they would that be
honest
no they give you a forecast it's you
know like it's any business i mean you
know
it's based on our experience based on
you know the marketplace and the
conditions and everything like that
the buyers this is what we estimate
we're going to generate for you
on this film and based on you know the
quality of your film here's our forecast
for your film
but they're just forecasts so we
hopefully will be close to them
hopefully we'll exceed them but
it's just an idea of what to expect it's
it's it's a ballpark of range are most
new independent filmmakers afraid to ask
that question yes of course they are
most new independent filmmakers are
afraid to ask anything to a distributor
because they're totally intimidated by
distributors
because they think distributors are for
some reason you know
smarter the holy grail or they're the
business people so you don't ask the
busy don't question the business people
you got to question everything and by
the way
what they do is a fraction of what
you've done as a
indie filmmaker what you've done in
making a movie
so far surpasses the amount of
of of passion and
and hard work that any distributor's
ever going to do
and i can speak from experience i know
what it takes to get a film made
and i know what it takes to get a film
sold now selling is a very very long
process and very difficult and you have
to be super persistent and you have to
be able to take a lot of rejection
making is super intense i mean staying
focused on story
and and setting actors and all this kind
of stuff and and just getting it all
together and delivering a great product
so they're different you know
disciplines and they're both important
but don't ever think what a distributor
does is any more difficult than what you
do
and don't ever be intimidated i mean i
can't say you're going to be intimidated
by them
they're going to push you they're going
to tell you things they're going to say
and that's why that's why lawyers and
consultants exist
so that you can take somebody in who an
agent
that's what these people do they just
say things to other people that you
might be too intimidated to say to them
so you pay somebody else to say it and
hopefully they're thinking something
else
is intimidation and rejection a muscle
that can be worked
i mean this is way beyond film
discussion this is this is
human behavior but um certainly
did you say intimidation and rejection
okay let's talk about rejection
if you don't have the capacity to deal
with rejection
you can't be in the film business you
can't you can't be in the indie part of
the film business you can work in the
film you can
you know be a you know gripper gaffer or
something like that or
don't be an actor that's for sure i mean
or don't be a director
anything that's super artistic or super
business related to the indie film
business
you got to make you got to be able to
deal with rejection
lots of it and you got to know how to
not take it personally
it's part of the it's part of the whole
process and the business
you got to if if you don't have to deal
with it
you got lucky chances are you're gonna
deal with it all the time
so it's an anomaly not to deal with it
the norm is to be dealing with lots of
rejection
okay intimidation that's a
personal thing you know it depends how
confident you are
and the person on the other side i mean
sometimes they'll have position over you
like for instance you know if you're if
you're sitting in a netflix meeting
and they have the ability to change your
life
and think about it they green light your
movie it changes your life
it changes the whole trajectory of your
life and they don't green light it it
changes it
in a different direction it doesn't end
your life it just you know slows it down
a little bit or something
um that can be intimidating
that's also nate to the nature of the
beast um you know unfortunately and uh
you just gotta know that um
you i related to poker you got a hand
you got to play it the way you think is
the best way to play it and whatever the
results are that's the results and
you know you can't kick yourself you
don't want to kick yourself for playing
your hand
wrong you want to make sure after the
game's over that you feel good about how
you played
but you don't always win and you got to
remember that that you're just not
always going to win
but you got to control your tells
scratching of the nose getting worried
because maybe that affects the deal if
they realize how easily you can be
pushed around
um yeah it's funny like
i guess i'm not very easily intimidated
so it's hard for me to relate to what
you're talking about
i mean perhaps maybe i
because i sat on the other side of the
intimidation equation for so long i
maybe i intimidate more than i get
intimidated
i mean it's almost a game for me to be
the intimidation thing's almost a bit of
a game it is a game sort of for me
but i understand that it's not for
everybody else and people get very
nervous and they're in environments that
they're not comfortable with especially
in those distribution
environments that can change your life
so yeah i mean i wish i was more of a
psychologist to be able to deal with
that but
you know i don't know that that is
really a behavioral psychologist
question how to deal with that
personally
what filmmaking mistake has cost you the
most money to think about that
um the money
it's funny how you ask that question you
see when you ask that question it
it i it right away my mind jumps to what
production things have cost me the most
in terms of
extra costs that i've incurred but the
real question is
what opportunity cost have i lost in
terms of selling or positioning a movie
that's the bigger bigger cost lost
opportunity
so in terms of production you're always
going to make some mistakes
you know it's just human nature you
can't get everything perfect i mean
experience helps not to make those
mistakes but
and then there's situations that you
can't control weather equipment failure
stuff like that so you got to be able to
juggle that
and deal with it and you know sometimes
afterwards you say oh i should have done
this or i should have done that or
something like that or
or i missed this that's life you plan as
much as you can
you hope to deal with everything so you
try to avoid those costly errors
and i'd say you know luckily for the
most part i have but you know
you can't be perfect you can't you can't
bat a hundred in this game
the opportunity cost lost is you know
deals that uh it's funny we just talked
about intimidation and
and and the whole poker game and
everything like that
and i've said lots about um you know how
to push
a distributor and maybe sometimes i
probably have pushed a little too much
and i maybe left some business on the
table
because i don't like to get pushed
around so maybe i push back a bit
more than i should one could say you
know if i i'd have to do an inventory
and say you know
maybe i lost this deal and i shouldn't
have but i got this deal and it was
better than it would have been
maybe it all netted out frankly i
haven't spent much time
regretting i don't tend to do that i'm
not that kind of person i i
tend to look forward and not backwards
you learn from your mistakes and you
you keep them in the past you try to
remember what you learned and you move
forward
so i i don't i don't spend a lot of time
it's hard for me to even to remember
some of the mistakes i made and i'm sure
i made lots of them
yeah it would be almost impossible to
measure a missed the cost of a missed
opportunity
sometimes you can sometimes there's uh
look at this is like negotiating a house
right
you really really really want to okay
let's say you're the seller forget the
buyer
you're the seller and you really want to
sell your house but you want a price
you want a million dollars for your
house a buyer comes in at 9
50. you go you're at 1-1
you go down to you know 1.050
they move up to 960.
at what point and then you know then you
stick to you know
1 million that's my price there it they
go to 9.70
if you take it or don't you take it you
said i want that i want that million
dollars
now you might not take it because you
think the next person is going to pay
you the million are going to pay you you
know
that's thirty thousand dollars that you
might be leaving on the table
and in the grand scheme it's three
percent of the purchase but it's still
thirty thousand dollars
right and you truly believe you're gonna
get a million dollars
do you walk away from it if you walk
away
and you don't get another buyer you
could regret that the rest of your life
if you take the deal you could also
regret it because you'll always
second-guess whether you could have had
that extra 30 000.
so it depends on the type of person you
are and how you deal with those kind of
things
i tend to say i'm going to do this
here's my deal here's
here's what i want to do and then i put
it behind me
i don't torment myself for going forward
it's not worth it
it's just not worth it but then you know
you take the 970 and the next day
the agent says oh my god you can't
believe this we just got an offer for
1.2 but
but it's too late we already signed the
other one you kick yourself
circumstances life you got to go on you
got to move you can't do that to
yourself
or the market crashes or the market
crashes you go i did the right thing you
did the right thing
so you know hindsight's 20 this is the
monday morning quarterback you know
heinz it's real easy
to do it in hindsight when does a
distributor start paying a filmmaker
and how often can a filmmaker expect
payment so
on a typical distribution deal the
first two years the filmmaker will get
reported to quarterly
so every every three months right that's
generally what happens and then
thereafter it's usually
every six months for the next two years
and then once a year for
going forward so generally the way they
do it is
they report the first quarter and then
they the payment that if you're owed any
money from the first quarter
it gets paid at the end of the second
quarter so it's usually shifted one
quarter
later so if the first quarter is say 90
days
you'll get paid in at the end of the
second quarter 180 days from the first
quarter payment
that's generally how it's done and you
just you know i mean you can ask for it
before but they generally won't do that
it's very standard practice to do it
that way
what's the typical length of a licensing
deal
well there's a a distribution deal
i mean distributors now are asking for
crazy long deals
i mean i i like three-year deals
distributors who were listening to this
would laugh and say yeah you're kidding
so i'd say five to seven years is a
typical deal
distributors asking for 15 years some of
them i shake my head and roll my eyes
and say you're kidding like
and but filmmakers do it because they
don't know any better so they'll do that
i don't think it's a good idea to do
more than five years unless there is
a like i say with a threshold
performance thresholds built in
sometimes i'll do say three years with
auto renewals based on hitting certain
performance thresholds
so if they hit this certain level then
it automatically renews for another
three years that's a fair deal also
because they're hitting targets and you
want to continue to do business with
them
so but you don't want long long terms
that tie your film up forever especially
with no
outs based on performance what happens
when a distributor goes out of business
it's tricky
it's like when any business goes out of
business you become a creditor
and you stand in line with all the other
creditors and
uh it's messy really really messy
it's like any you know receivership
situation
or worse because sometimes they don't
even go into receivership they just
disappear
and you can't even find them so it's
that's why you kind of want to deal with
reputable companies if you can and
hopefully they have enough business
acumen and wherewithal and staying power
that you know even if they do run into
trouble
they can get through it but you know
when a small company goes out of
business there's
nothing left and there's nobody to even
sue for anything and by the way if
you're going to do a lawsuit it'll cost
you more than what you're probably going
to collect
sure so if if
the if it goes into some kind of a
bankruptcy proceeding
then you can apply to be one of the
creditors yeah well you automatically
are a creditor i mean if you're
you know if you have a distribution
contract i mean you have to
yeah they'll contact you you'll fill out
the paperwork and you know you'll say
that
you want to it's a typical receivership
situation
okay but for those who've never been in
that situation
then if you're if if if a company goes
into bankruptcy
and your name is in their books and they
have a contract with you you would
automatically be on the court paperwork
no okay well here's the key actually i'm
glad you mentioned this the key thing
with the
with the receiver bankruptcy situation
or receivership
is getting your money is going to be
almost if there's money owing to you
it's going to be almost impossible to
get it it's it's
super super super tricky to get through
that and it's super messy
make sure you get your rights back the
key is that you
got to make sure that the contract
there's a generally all distribution
contracts
have a termination clause for that would
be considered a substantial or
a um i forget the word breach you know
like a um
forget the legal term a big breach and
um
so a major breach so therefore it would
automatically terminate the contra
the deal and your rights would come back
but you
need to make sure that you that you
paper that
that you document it that that you've
the
contract's been terminated and you have
the rights because otherwise those
rights could sit
in receivership forever and be and what
we call chain of title could get muddied
and therefore you won't be able to sell
it to anybody else because you won't
have a clean chain of title
i hadn't even thought of that so it's
just that's the most important thing
so even if a company is defunct it
doesn't mean that your rights
have been terminated as as well as any
payments to you
and it's got to be well documented i
mean it should
mean that but it might go into some
holding pattern or something like i'm
not a bankruptcy expert
sure but sometimes these things take
years and years and years to resolve
and you get tied up with it so you need
to clean that up right away before you
clean up the money situation
so then you would have trouble going to
a new distributor because you don't have
a clean
chain of title that's correct oh wow
yeah
yeah because they'll see that you know
potentially there's somebody else
the receivers you know might have the
chain of title i mean somebody else
might or somebody might buy that company
at a receivership because they want
those contracts
wow but that happens actually that's
that's very common
i mean there's value to those
distribution contracts because there's
revenue streams coming in
so if somebody can pick up the entire
company in the whole library
you know 10 cents on the dollar that's a
really good deal
and you kind of get screwed ah so if if
someone came in
but took over their inventory
are the are your contract is your
contract going to be
those those same rights will revert to
the new company unless they
unless they're automatically terminated
or you have provided for termination or
you you know or you
claim a breach i would say in that it
would be better if you want to deal with
the new company
in the case of where the receivership is
you know selling to a new buyer
terminate with the old company and
contract with the new company as opposed
to having them
buy it out but you have to make sure you
have that term in your contract right
that it's and that's pretty standard
that's one of those boilerplate terms
but make sure it's in there your 2004
film my brother's keeper
do you still have the same distributor
that you did at
2004. technically because that
distributor was myself
i self-distributed it i mean i owned a
distribution company and i still own a
distribution company so yeah the answer
would be
they happen to be different companies
one was in canada one was in the u.s but
i still
i could i own both of those companies so
i would answer that yes they're the same
distributor it's me
okay so you haven't had to renegotiate
your own contract
so for instance i licensed that movie to
many television
networks um and primarily they were
three to four year deals when i first
did them so they've
expired those licenses have expired and
so and i
and i own the movie so now um i've taken
back those rights and i've re-licensed
them
sometimes to the same broadcaster but
sometimes to a different broadcaster in
the same territory so like if you know
here in the united states
not that i did this but like let's say
you licensed to nbc on your first
round um when that expires after four
years you can go and license into abc
now nobody licenses nbc or abc except
for they're like no
i just use that as an example okay but
so so i've since
licensed out a second round um in that
case there's actually a third round
um the only long-term
contract and these have all expired like
i had a
dvd back then i was doing dvds right so
there was a long term i think it was a
seven year dvd distribution deal which
obviously expired also
um with so i don't do i didn't do
physical dvd distribution of my company
i did it when i worked for other people
so i know how it works
but i didn't want to be in manufacturing
all that kind of stuff so i did a long
term deal with them
they put it out to the marketplace it's
since expired so i could
read up that with them or somebody else
but there aren't really any dvd sales
anymore so you know those rights are
sitting
idle and there's some international
deals
that so basically i have taken back all
the rights on that film from what i
licensed the first time around i made
some other deals
a fraction of what i did the first time
around because like i said most of the
good deals are done in the first round
once a film gets especially an indie
film if it's a classic
you know if i had it's a wonderful life
i'd license it over and over well that's
public domain but something you know
shawshank redemption you license it over
and over and over and over
and it actually gains value probably um
you know forrest gump
all the classics right but not indie
films indie films tend to
lose momentum after a while so the
second and third round of licensing like
you know
say they're four to five year periods
tend to get less robust
much less so you're lucky if you get
anything you know
after the first round unless let's
suppose the original licensing
had a star in it who wasn't very well
known and then
maybe a decade later becomes
a-less talent yeah that's like finding a
lottery ticket in your drawer
that hasn't expired yet
no no it's great and and it does happen
okay it does happen and people do it all
the time they say hey let's re-release
this movie because
you know all of a sudden you know tom
hanks was a child when we made it now
he's a superstar
yeah right yeah no it happens for sure
when a licensing deal expires
what happens they send you paperwork to
renew
or how does this work you track it so um
if you're a distributor or you're
dealing with a distributor
you have extensive uh records so you
have a database
it's generally on a spreadsheet so and
it think of it this you have
all the rights and all the territories
so you say and all the periods so um so
you say okay
here's this film i'm you know it's italy
spain france
germany you know uk and i license it to
you know this broadcaster in france
for this period of time and it goes on
to a spreadsheet
so that you can monitor when it expires
so that's what all distributors have
they have these these huge extensive
databases of all the films that they
have and all the rights that they've
licensed for what periods of time to
which
contact and and it gets triggered now
it's all computerized it gets triggered
and says okay this is expiring now it's
available for re-licensing or doing it
somewhere else and it's very important
to keep track of all that
because you don't want to do you know
two deals and you can't
it would be illegal to license you know
the same rights to two people
so you have to keep really good records
of that and distributors do that
i mean that's they all have these very
you know robust fancy databases that
keep track of that i do it on a
spreadsheet
i don't have that many films so you know
the ones i self-distribute i'm able to
keep track of all those deals
so you're not only having them keep
track of it but you have your own
records
well for the most part i don't deal with
distributors i am the distributor
sure so if and when i do deal with a
distributor yeah
i keep my own records because i'm super
diligent that way because
i care about all that stuff i want to
know when the deals are expiring
because you know sometimes they i
shouldn't use this
conveniently forget to tell you
conveniently but sometimes they just
generally you know it's honestly forget
to tell you so i will
say to a distributor you know according
to my records this deal
has now expired you know is and and the
license is over
and i'm taking the rights back we're not
renewing
right and there's nothing like an auto
renew you know how yeah there are oh
there are
you can write that into a contract okay
you can say you know it'll
yeah you can do auto renews if you want
i i tend to not do them because there's
no reason to because i'd rather
renegotiate something
but some people do sure sure and i'm
thinking from the perspective of an
independent filmmaker who's not a
distributor you know
how should they keep records and not
just wait to get something in the mail
or not get something yeah they're
probably not going to keep records
because they don't like to do that they
don't want to be involved in that and
it's not artistic and it's not what they
do
so you know but uh it's not that hard to
right and once you have a couple painful
lessons then you go yeah i'm gonna start
keeping records or
or find somebody who can keep it for you
i don't know an accountant something i
don't know somebody who
doesn't mind doing that kind of thing
it's not hard to do it's
one entry every four to five years and
you just have to
have a trigger point to you i mean you
have to look at it you know maybe once a
month and see what's coming up and just
remind yourself
is it a good idea for a filmmaker to
pitch a distributor their idea before
they pitch
an investor their idea excellent idea
it's the best idea i'll tell you why
because if they can get a distributor
interested it'll make the pitch to the
investor so much easier
because a smart investor they're going
to ask the first question they're going
to ask is not what's the movie about
frankly they don't care they're going to
ask how are you going to sell it and how
much you're going to make with it
that's what investors care about it's
called return on investment roi
all right so if the answer to that
question is funny you should ask that
because
i actually have a distribution deal and
i've got sales forecasts here and this
is what we think we're going to make
from it from this legitimate distributor
who's been in this business for 25 years
and knows what they're doing
that is a super compelling pitch to an
investor
way better than oh we're going to find
that out and let you know here's my
guess
it's the way to do it and so a
prospective indie filmmaker
will do what they'll find a list of
distributors
in their niche they'll email a
very brief email saying here's my idea i
mean
how do you do how do you pitch someone
before you even have the filmmaking yeah
this gets tricky this is called put on
your dancing shoes and
and uh or some people call burning the
candle at both ends
where basically you're gonna
tell your distributor your potential
distributor what
you sort of already have and you're
going to tell your investor
what this distributor sort of is going
to tell you
you're i don't it's it's not you this is
salesmanship
all right this is this is the art of
pitching and
and developing and selling all right
so you're an investor and you want to
hear
that a distributor is already interested
because when you hear that you'll be
more interested
but now you're a district you're a
distributor
but you don't really care about the
guy's investor what you care about is
did you make the movie yet
so basically what you want to hear that
you're going to make a
really good movie and this could be
something so you almost have to say to
the distributor
in some ways you just have to fess up
and you have to say look
i haven't made the movie yet but i'm
going to make this kick-ass
great movie it's going to be fantastic
and you have to go into a lot more
detail unless they ask you about that
um i think you'd be the right
distributor for it i'm not asking you
for any guarantees right now
all i'm asking you for is to ex
show me in writing express some interest
that i've spoken to you
and that this could be something that we
would be interested in after you make it
that might be you know valuable and if
and if it's as good as you say it's
going to be it could generate 2 million
in sales
no commitments very airy fairy language
very very light
it's not any type of legal document that
you could ever
finance or rely on or anything but it's
better than not having it
at least it's you the investor sees you
made the effort to go to the
distributor to have the conversation to
at least get into the ballpark to at
least
get an understanding and they'll feel
more confident with that
so theoretically you have two phones and
you're running back and forth
not theoretically for real for real okay
yeah for real that's what you're doing
and you're
you're i call it the dance you're doing
the dance and you're dancing at two
parties at the same time and hoping that
you don't fall over
but that's what everybody does i mean
that's how it's not just the film
business that's how a lot of projects i
mean
biotech you know you know high tech all
this a lot of stuff gets financed that
way
because you got nothing right you got an
idea unless you have a track record
you know then who are you you got a guy
with an idea or a girl with an idea who
just you know has a vision people can't
buy into that so you have to start
really slowly and get
make tiny little steps both ways until
you can
that's why i say burn the camera you got
to just bring it closer and closer and
closer until
boom you got it jeff is this how you've
approached your previous film
yeah i'd say i'm a pretty good tap
dancer my wife would tell you
that i'm not a good dancer at all but
she hasn't seen me in business
she just sees me on the real dancer no i
know how to do the dance
um it's it's look at first of all
i would say i'm and i think anybody
who's dealt with me would say i'm a
pretty honest person
um so if somebody says hey you know
where you at with this have you made it
i'd say no i haven't made it it's an
idea
but until they ask me that it's going to
feel like it's not an idea it's going to
feel like it's
way more developed because in like you
need to hold people's hand through the
process
people are very seasoned and know all
about it they're a walk in the park
but a lot of people aren't seasoned so
you just have to need to hold their hand
and get them over the hump get them to
share the vision
and and it really involves a lot of
finessing and
and timing and you know don't push too
hard here don't push it
you got to push a little like i said you
got to make little steps each way to get
up to the thing
so that boom you can get what you want
done to bring
you know kind of two elements together
financing and distribution which are
closely related
the revenue stream and the cash flow
those are very closely related concepts
and
and you know sometimes it takes a lot of
juggling i think a lot of
indie filmmakers fail at that i mean
it's very very difficult
to do that it's it's a bit of an art and
there are people who are really really
good at it as you've seen
and uh you know that's what investment
bankers do
frankly and that's what venture
capitalists do
they just bring ideas to life by
bringing parties together bringing money
together with
with sales why do you think a lot of
independent filmmakers fail at it
because they're too anxious they're way
way way too anxious and they jump the
gun a little bit
well first of all they don't know
distribution well enough so they don't
put enough weight on the sales side and
the revenue generation
side and they put most of it on the
artistic side so when they're
for the most part when they're pitching
an investor they're telling them how
good the movie is going to be and how
good it's going to look and it's going
to be fantastic and we'll be able to
sell it
i never start that way with investors i
always say
here's what the marketplace will bear
here's what we think we're going to do
we're going to
generate a million and a half dollars on
a million dollar budget or
on a 800 000 budget the roi is going to
be this
oh and by the way here's the movie
i've never had an investor ask me to
read a script i mean i'd give them a log
line
they don't care why should they care
they're investing in you your ability to
make a film and your ability to sell the
film that's what they're investing in
now the bells and whistles and the fun
stuff for an investor are
hey can i come on set can i do a cameo
can i read the script
can my kid be in the movie you know
that's the bells and whistles and that's
the icing on the cake and you throw all
that in because you know you want to do
some
the deal and make it fun for everybody
but the core essence of the investment
is
are you going to be able to deliver the
really good film that you said you can
and are you going to be able to sell it
and how do i know you can sell it
how do i know you can make it hopefully
you've
made some other stuff or you surround
yourself by good filmmakers or whatever
that's the credibility thing
how do we know you're going to sell it
you're dealing with people who've sold
before
you have surrounded yourself in those
circles and
you know although we know it's a risk
it's not sold it's not pre-sold we know
there's a risk there
but at least you're thinking about it
and you're planning for it
that's a good thing which is what most
indie filmmakers don't do
because they don't like to do that out
of the seven feature films that you've
made jeff
how many times have you gone to the
distributor
first before you've gone to the investor
every time
i i wouldn't go to an investor until i
have a distribution plan
there's no point in pitching an investor
unless you have
a complete plan of how you're going to
generate revenue
because that's the number one question
that they that they ask you and that's
what you have to lead with
it's an investment now but remember
this is a business for me right so if
it's a business for me it's a business
for my investors
i've never gone to uncle charlie and
said you know what uncle charlie
i'm dying to make a film and i need
somebody to pay for it and don't expect
to get any money i need a donation
i've never done that because that's not
what who i am and what i do
i've always gone to people and said
uncle charlie um what are you investing
in real estate you know what are you
making you're making eight percent on
your money i'll show you a place that
you can make 15
i got a film and here's the cash flow on
it and here's my revenue projections
and the reason you should believe this
is because i've distributed 50 other
films like this
here's what the marketplace looks like
and you know you can make some serious
money on this
and here's the time frame it's going to
take and here's how the cash flow works
and all this kind of stuff
and he says oh that's interesting what's
the film
most filmmakers say oh i've got this
great film it's a it's a
rom-com and it's going to be great and
it's going to start this and here's the
story and here's the plot lines and
here's the beats and here's this and all
the kind of stuff
and they never get to the roi and the
revenue because
you're an investor you're putting money
in now remember if you're looking for
the donation
do it differently if you're looking for
an investor who actually wants to make a
return on investment you gotta
show them the investment you got to lead
with the money so i would never
even bother pitching an investor until i
have totally mapped out the
distribution and revenue generation plan
and you know for the most part i
self-distribute sorry i able to do that
myself
but there are cases recently you know
where
where i've worked on other people's
films where i have
mapped out their entire revenue
generation plan long before they've even
tapped into an investor
by the way there was a case one of my
clients and i won't name them
but if they're watching they know who
they are they came to me
and they said um i've been pitching my
potential investor group
and they're not biting can you help me
and i said what's your pitch and they
showed it to me and i said you're just
talking about the film
if i was investor what i would i would
have no interest investing because
you're asking for a donation here so
that you can you know make a film
let's rejig it and i said i i'll pitch
for you but you can't be there because
you're going to spend too much time
talking about the movie
and you're going to be aggravated that
all i talk about is the investment so
i went and pitched all of his investor
group
including all of his relatives like
we're talking
you know parents all this kind of stuff
you know and and um
and just talked about the money and then
and they said okay now it's an
investment
before it was a donation now it's an
investment thank you very much
this makes sense you sure you can do it
and i said yeah and i charged him
a pretty big fee to do it and uh and i
also
arranged all his distribution for him
too which i also charged a fee for
but because of that not only did he get
his financing but he actually made the
movie and he actually sold the movie
so it all worked out people got you know
what they bargained for
and i was pretty confident that i could
sell that movie
and i actually said you know in some
ways i kind of pre-sold it
the only reason i didn't pre-sell is
because i wasn't making it so i had to
make sure that he was going to make the
move that he could deliver the movie
that i was
negotiating for but my credibility's at
stake too
so i wasn't you know it was his movie
not mine
i didn't have creative control over it
so i was prepared to
go a certain distance but if he didn't
deliver a good movie i didn't want to
take
a distributor's money for a movie that
wasn't good
because i have you know i have pride and
credibility too at stake
what's the time frame of getting
investors versus getting distributors
i do it simultaneously you do it at the
same time because
they more or less take the same amount
of time um and then it's not a linear
thing it's it's
a parallel situation so basically as i'm
pitching
distributors i'm also lining up
investors and pitching them
but i'm i've done the work that the
distributor is going to do for me
already
i've already done all the revenue
forecasts and all i need them to do is
sign off on them
so i'm already pitching the investors
saying that this is who it's going to be
or this is what the numbers are going to
look like
and they say who's the distributor if i
pitch early
before i have a distributed then i'll
say well i'm talking to these three
and i'm in negotiations right now but
we're all in the same area this is sort
of the numbers and i'll
line that up afterwards but at least i
have three on the table
and i might not i might have five i
might have two but you know
you just it's part of the the i
shouldn't call it the dance it's
it's part of the process you know it's
it's a real part and
and um you know you're gonna get one
like i know i'm gonna get one of the
three
um and i might get a bidding award it
might be better than what
what i have pitched to them but um
they both need to hear like the
distributor also doesn't want to gauge
get engaged until they know that you
have financing to make your movie so
when you say hey guess what i'm you know
i have a
investor meeting tonight i got you know
six investors coming to my house
and i'm pitching them and if you give me
this document there's a good chance i
can green light it and if i green light
it
you're going to get to distribute it so
there's incentive on that side also
where are you getting the information
for these forecasts
well again i get it because i've been in
distribution my whole life so i
i forecast it myself based on my own
experience and everything
you know what the key thing is i this is
what i've said this and i don't know if
this is even possible
but it would be a perfect world if
coming at a film school
all young indie filmmakers got hooked up
with a mentor
an experienced mentor that would be the
way to launch people's careers
because all the stuff that we're talking
about really comes with experience
the all the credibility comes with
experience you have to have made the
mistakes
so um but it takes years and years and
years to get there to make the mistakes
so
it would be more of a launch pad if an
indie filmmaker could come at a film
school
have their hand held by you know this
happens in like
think of what doctors do doctors go for
four year
um you know residencies four years
they get their hands held so that you
know because they you know medicine
doesn't want to put somebody in the
field until they're
super super confident that they've
already learned all this stuff right
what if we did that in filmmaking like
hooked these young filmmakers up with
experienced filmmakers
and had the experienced filmmakers
helped navigate all these challenges
getting a distributor you know pitching
to investors
you know maybe even helping them develop
or you know teaching them how to
properly make their films on time and on
budget
this would be super helpful for indie
filmmakers who it's
very difficult to navigate that one you
don't know what you're doing
two you're not credible even if you
didn't know what you're doing nobody's
going to believe you know what you're
doing because you've never done it
before
i mean there's just these big hurdles
that you know that you have to overcome
that
really come with time and so if you had
somebody by your side like you know
experienced doctor holding the hand of a
resident
and making sure they don't make a
mistake but letting them learn on their
own
you know or letting them make a mistake
even and then correcting it afterwards
that could be super helpful so i don't
know how that could work but
that that's really what would be
great for in the film they they need to
they need to hook themselves up with
if they want to get a like a high budget
feature made like when i say a high
budget you know anything like above
a half a million dollars which is in the
hobby film which is a real movie which
is you know potentially distributable
and can get on to you know a streaming
service
they got to almost be connected with a
with an experienced filmmaker so that
they'll be taken
seriously they could be a better
filmmaker than experienced filmmaker
maybe more talented
but the experienced filmmaker has the
credibility from years of doing it and
knows how to
say the right things to the right people
in the right tone
and just can help them over those
hurdles otherwise you know you could
stumble and fall for a long long time
waiting a lot of lines you know never
get those distribution meetings
you know never really landed a true
investor it's
it's tricky to juggle it all do you
think in some ways though hand holding
prevents
it makes it too easy for people that
sometimes it's good to help people
it prevents learning and it also doesn't
build resiliency
i see a lot of people that have had
their hands held they're not resilient
and they almost need some of these hard
knocks i think there could be a nice
combination of the two
i think there comes a time when you've
learned the lesson
you've you've fallen you've been gotten
up by yourself a couple times and you
can just use
a little bit of a helping hand there's a
balance there is a balance
because i don't think that the real
world there's not a lot of helping hands
and i'm not saying that it's totally why
don't we let doctors
struggle through it well that's a little
different because they're saving lives
well they're they're opening up
someone's aorta yeah fair enough i mean
no i don't i don't know if i want but
but plumbers
have like five-year residency or
something i mean you
yeah they can mess things up okay so
filmmaker can't totally mess things up
but you know they
well yeah fair enough you know i mean
i'm not saying that it's not important
and you could say the same for
entrepreneurs as well and
and other businesses but sometimes i
think
too much hand-holding spoils people and
then they don't learn the right lessons
i i totally agree the school of hard
knocks is the best teacher i totally
agree with you
yeah but at some point you've been
knocked so many times and it's just you
just have to get over a hurdle
and once you you've already you're
appreciated you appreciate that
you can't get over that hurdle without
some mentoring and then you get over it
and you get knocked around a little bit
more
there's a balance yeah i'm sure there is
it's that's what goes on in parenting
you just got to find that right balance
of how much to protect your child
and how much to let them you know fall
and stumble and get back
up yeah because in business there's
there's not a lot of
of heart and hand-holding from the other
side correct okay but
only in the indian world in in the in
the studio world
everybody gets their hand held
everybody's protected everybody's got
these big crews and all these protection
mechanisms around them and nobody really
can fail by themselves so they're in
this very comfortable environment
you have to really mess up to on a you
know in a big
film crew or whatever um but getting in
that world is really tricky
right that's true but you know you're
talking about the entrepreneurial world
where
you know you're out there alone and you
i don't know
i agree with you but there maybe could
be more of a balance i mean
what would be so terrible after somebody
stumbled and fall a few times and says
hey
you know i just can't get over this
hurdle just to help them over it and let
them get on to the next thing and
hopefully they'll remember that
that they stumbled and fell and got some
help and maybe you know yeah
let's pass it forward play it you know
yeah that would be nice jeff a lot of
filmmakers
complain about getting well for lack of
a better word i guess screwed
by distributors with hidden costs and
different things
can you talk about how this happens and
what filmmakers
should look out for yeah that's it's
it's very real
i mean a lot of filmmakers the right
word is screwed
um it's they all of a sudden
um you get a statement and you owe them
money because they've spent so much
money on
marketing and this kind of stuff and you
think like where did that go
so listen a lot of it's real i spoke
about marketing and how important it is
and you should tuck away a lot of money
to market
so the distributor is marketing for you
hopefully they're spending lots of money
on your behalf to market your film to
get it out there you want them to do
that
the only problem is sometimes they will
spend in areas that benefit
them and not you i'll give you a great
example okay
film markets so they attend most
distributors attend you know at least
five or six major film markets a year
and it's expensive really like i don't
know if you've ever been to canada or
berlin or
it's you go there hotel rooms are
fortunate especially jack them up during
those festivals and you know those
markets
um they have to fly you know and they
fly first class sometimes and and they
eat fancy meals and
entertain a lot of people with expensive
bottles of wine and this kind of thing
now that's good because hopefully
they're making sales
but if they're not making sales that
cost is coming right back to you
and you're paying for that and they they
disseminate that cost
through all the films that they
represent and now the thing is
you know a lot of them charge a flat fee
for markets plus
so it's general market attendance fee
plus direct expenses related so here
would be so let's say you get charged i
don't know ten thousand dollars for them
on your film gets charged ten thousand
dollars for them to attend can
but then they take somebody out for
dinner and and basically talk about your
film
supposedly only your film um and that
dinner costs you know six hundred
dollars that comes
you get charged back um if they talked
about
five films hopefully all of them got but
sometimes they charge the full six
hundred dollars to all five films
that's that's this when people talk
about getting screwed
they don't even know how badly they're
getting screwed like that's stuff that's
not even auditable you can never
you what are you going to relive that
dinner you're going to say hey
like and they they don't even tabulate
it that way it's not like they say oh
here's a dinner and can
between this person and this person and
him which it's not like a lawyer who
gives you a log
right they say can you know market
expense
and um ancillary expenses for your film
only in another
4 500 you say what was that well we had
to
entertain people we had to do this you
never know and you never know if they
charged every single film that
so chances are they're making more money
off of that than they are
off of selling your films that's the
screwing that people talk about
and it's very real it happens a lot on a
regular basis
because it's so easy to do it's so easy
to get away with it it's
almost unauditable that's the trust
factor
so how do you prevent it you put a cap
on your expenses
you say to the in the contract you say
you you can't spend more than you know
say five percent of
the revenue that you're generating
unless you get sign off from me
so if you want to do an additional
expense say and run an ad
you know do another market do this that
then i have to sign off
and give approval and distributors don't
like that because they don't like to
be accountable and sign off but that's
how you prevent it it's one of the only
ways to prevent it
and it's it's a pretty common thing to
do i do i mean it's
i wouldn't do a distribution deal
without that because expenses can run
wild
but it's not in the boiler plate that
they get no of course not so okay so
it's in the boiler plate that i give i
remember i have the boiler
i have the i have in my files the the
independent producer boilerplate
contract that they should use for
distribution and the distributors have
the
distributor boilerplate contract that
they would use and there's some
major differences sure all that all the
terms are the same but the way
they're skewed you know mine tend to
skew more
favor of the producer right and then you
come to
but that's that's the classic screwing
and the there's another classics
there's there's two other ones actually
oh please second one is
reporting of revenues like how would you
ever know if a deal got done
that didn't get reported let's say they
sell your movie
to a uh you know a cable t station
in greece i mean you don't even know the
cable stations in greece
let alone how much they sold it for and
if the contract ever got negotiated or
done or whatever so unreported revenue
sometimes happens and you know
distributors who watch this are going to
say no we never do that but they do
they do it happens unfortunately
and then there is
what we call the term is called
cross-collateralization
and it is where you're taking either a
pool of films or you're taking a pool of
rights
this is where it gets this is where it
gets this is a concept that
will make indie filmmakers head spin
it's not even complicated but it's just
so let's say you say to the your
distributor
we want you to sell say there's two ways
it happens
three of our films or we're going to
sell one of our films
in 15 different territories so let's say
that in the uk
film number one they make a great deal
on it
right but in the ussr
film number two they make a terrible
deal but they spent a lot of money
in you know in traveling there or
whatever so they take
the pr the revenue of one deal and cross
it over
with the costs of another deal so the
costs
neutralize the revenue meaning you get
nothing and they get their cost paid by
your revenue
so they're taking a pool now they can do
that with
shared rights shared films or sometimes
they'll do it with a whole pool of
films that you don't even own it could
be just a whole collection of other
films
and they'll cross everything over and
and
neutralize it all so that they make a
bigger fee
and you get stuck with all the costs
because they don't want to get stuck
with the cost they want all those costs
disseminated through
through the the system and this is where
it gets messy
now i have audited distributors before
like major distribution generally i it's
almost a waste of time to audit the
small guys
the public companies those are the ones
you audit
and it's
messy i mean there are
all kinds of things that i i could tell
you is i i'll tell you one story
so i had a film i'm not going to go into
the details
i put it out i this one i used through a
distributor
for certain territories i was
self-distributing the film for
for major territories but there are
other territories that i don't deal with
because they're too
complicated language issues cultural
issues i mean i just don't have the
wherewithal to deal with everything so i
gave it to a distributor
they did some decent deals i knew they
did the deals because
i was able on by the internet you can go
on and see where they're playing and
what the schedule is you can you can
verify this stuff you know you can also
phone the just the
broadcasters and say okay when's it
playing what's going on blah blah blah
so i knew the deals had been done and
they also had done
some vod um you know digital deals and i
saw
that it was trending really well there's
some trending reports that you can look
at you can't get the sales but you can
see the trending
all right so i had a pretty good idea
that there were lots of sales
i get the first report back and it's
zero zero revenue
and i said guys this is impossible i
know for a fact
that you sold australia how do you know
because i spoke to the australian
broadcaster and they told me they have
your movie i'm friends with them
i know for it's impossible that you
don't have revenue
let me let's check they check the system
oh you're right you know what
this deal got um it's called mapping it
got
mapped into a different revenue stream
it went to another i said you guys are
public company you can't i mean mapping
errors okay fine
i said there's more there that's not
enough
there's so much more going on they said
no there isn't jeff i said
fine i'm gonna audit you i audited them
you have to spend money you have to get
an auditor you make appointments public
company it's a big deal to do an audit
very expensive but you know
anyway i found two hundred thousand
dollars in missing revenue on the first
audit
the first audit they said and they
danced around well
sorry this that mistake here mistake
there that's a lot of money
that is a lot of missing money it's only
a certain territory
right so um
so then i said okay fine i'm going to do
a so
then another three quarters passed and i
said i'm going to do another audit to
end the year
i go in i find another 50 000 so i say
i believe that there's still some
missing revenue here and here's why i
believe it
and i took them to arbitration because
in my contract i couldn't sue them i had
to
it was built in that was going to be
arbitrated cost me a lot of money to
arbitrate
they spent a ton of money on a big fancy
lawyer
and it went to an arbitrator and it took
six months and
i thought it was going to be a slam dunk
but they out lawyered me
and i'm a lawyer and they outlaw and i
learned a really good lesson about legal
proceedings
and it's got nothing to do with film
reporting or film distribution it's all
about legal manipulation and how to game
the system
and they're a big public company and
they out lawyered me
and i know that i left a lot of money on
the table not to mention how much i
spent on the arbitration
and you asked me before you know is
there any regrets that i have i would
have dealt with that one differently but
you don't know that until after the fact
anyways how many indie film producers
after that i came home after that day
after the final this judgment on the
arbitration i said to my wife
i'm sick to my stomach about this but
i'm way sicker about
how many indie filmmakers have been
screwed by this company probably for the
last
decade thousands thousands of films have
probably lost
hundreds tens of millions of dollars
have been
left on the table because nobody
can afford to do what i did and i lost
i lost that's what goes on that goes on
all the time
and it's a shame and it would be great
if
somehow you know the world could i said
i'm going on a crusade i said to my wife
this is
it i'm going on a crusade i am gonna go
and i'm gonna
dig up everything from every public
company for every filmmaker and i'm
gonna be the hero
and she said just go to sleep you know
tomorrow morning you wake up you'll be a
calmer
you know that crusade would be a
lifetime thing for me and it would cost
10 million dollars in legal fees now if
i could put a fund together
from all the filmmakers you know to
represent them or if the filmmakers did
have representation
then and you know in some type of
protection agency or something like that
who could
represent them that would be fantastic
but they don't
indie filmmakers don't have any
associations like that they don't have
any to go it alone is impossible
it's costly and crazy and you don't know
what you're doing and it's and it's and
it's
you can't do it maybe to go to this
group but you know
they don't nobody's got any money so but
tens of millions of dollars have been
left on the table hundreds of millions i
can't even fathom how much
just based on my own experience how much
has been
screwed how how much indie filmmakers
have have
walked away from because they don't know
and even if they did know
be hard to get it and with the
collateralization
of these films with the distributor is
that similar just
cdos that what sunk the housing market
in some sense
the collateralized debt obligations no
no it's not the same
okay so it's it's but but so so they
package these films
and they sell them to these different
territories yes
let me give you another example okay
this really really irked me
but again you have to be able to dig
into the weeds
to get this example so another
distributor i was using
is also australia happened to be so they
sold a package
so they're representing many many many
films okay i was one film in a package
of probably say
25 that they sold to a
a broadcaster in in australia i got the
report
my number was like i don't know 75
dollars
for a like five-year deal broadcast deal
on
one of my best films it was like some
stupid number
like literally less than a hundred
dollars i phone them up and i say what
what is this
it's a five-year deal and you sold it
for 75 dollars well we did a package
deal you were one of a package
so we had to prorate the numbers i said
pro rate
like how much i'd like to see the pro
rating sorry we don't share that because
it's other privileged information for
other films
so of course i did a little digging only
to find out that you know
the 10 main films that were sold they
owned
not only the distribute they own them
they were proprietary
so what they did is they took everybody
else's films pretty well gave them away
for free
in order to get the revenue for their
films
that's a very common practice and
there's nothing you can do about it
i mean there's lots you can do if you
know about it and you can contract that
kind of thing also
but it's super super tricky
and you had a leg up and that you had a
friend
i knew so i knew the deal was there
right so so most people wouldn't be
privy to that information they wouldn't
know
first of all well you get reported it
was on the report you know and
there was a revenue number 75 or some
stupid number
so so at least they reported something
mean the other example i gave when is
when they don't report anything so you
never even know that
okay right no there's two types there's
they don't report anything so you can
never even question it because
you never even you don't know what are
you gonna go phone every territory
around the world and do research
every week and say hey i heard you sold
this to that you don't know
this is they reported it but it was so
low at least there's something you can
question
and then it was a package deal and
there's not much you can do if you
hadn't contracted against that because
that's their
privilege to do that i mean they
shouldn't it's wrong
but it happens is this the same type of
stuff that's going on in the music
industry
i don't music's not i mean you know i
know music um
but i'm i i think music's even worse
music is is just i mean first of all
it's an older industry
and it was a bigger industry for a while
and um
it's just so easy to cheat and pirate
music
and yeah i think it's worse
it's it's it's a real problem with all
intellectual property
software anything like that anything
that's hard to like you know that
it's hard to well it's i guess it's a
problem with anything
anybody who does dishonest business
right i mean you could have
hard products too and inventory and you
know sometimes it disappears and it was
destroyed or returned or this or that i
mean you know that happens all over the
place
sure they call it shrinkage that's
exactly right
that's what it's called shrinkage so
maybe that's what we should call it in
the
film industry but uh there seems to be a
lot of it
so that's part of you know hopefully
knowing what you're doing and paying
attention but it's it's not easy
sure and now a lot of things can be
blamed on computer error
before maybe human error everything
everything that's that's exactly what's
called a mapping error
mapping means that revenues flow in and
then they get disseminated to each of
the films
that's the map and and they claimed
because i was going to sue them after
arbitration but they claimed
to the arbitrator that the mapping was
wrong and they showed you know
and i said guys it's a real problem that
a public company your size has mapping
errors
can you imagine if we started digging
how many mapping errors i mean like i'm
a little tiny
pebble in an ocean compared to what you
guys do i'm one little tiny independent
film
it's really bad that you got mapping
errors and so many of them
and i just went digging and i found that
and that's like surface stuff
yeah so you know maybe i shouldn't be
accusatory and say
that it happened on purpose but i am
saying that
and you have to pay for an arbitrator
correct oh yeah so you have to go to a
list of
no hold on when you initiate arbitration
not only you have to pay for
my side i had to pay for their side
that's the way arbitration works
wow yeah yeah it was
it was a pride thing and you know it's
just one of those stubborn
i just don't want to get taken advantage
of but the way the legal system works is
even if you win you lose you win the
battle and lose the war
because you know even if you win the
issue it costs you twice as much to
litigate it
sure so
such is life but the light at the end of
the tunnel is
that movie still was very successful and
i was
happy to have made it and if i focus on
the negatives then
i'll be miserable so i try to focus on
the pauses which is
what most people do um but uh you know
it's good to at least know what you're
doing so at least you have a shot
at getting it done properly
what's the difference between film
markets and film festivals
markets are generally not open to the
public they're for buyers they're for
industry
executives only so you're getting buyers
from around the world which are
acquisition people
and you know tv executives that type of
thing who are looking for product to
acquire
and then you have sellers which are
primarily distributors
and studios and that type of thing who
are selling product and so a market
would be a place where the two would
converge
and it wouldn't be open to the public
you have to have credentials to register
in one of those in a market
a festival and the big ones are obvious
i mean can has a festival and a market
at the same time
so they run parallel
so it's a lot of big festivals also have
markets that run parallel everybody
thinks they're just festivals the public
thinks they're festivals but the
professionals know there's markets
but there's like a lot of markets that
are just markets like the american film
market is just a market
it's not a film festival so there's no
the public can't attend it
they can't register for it they can't go
to see any films
a film festival is designed for
filmmakers to showcase their movies to
the public so the public's obviously
invited and
encouraged to come and watch as many
independent movies as po or whatever
movies or showcase there
um and it's a chance for uh you know a
filmmaker
to one celebrate their movie um
you know because they made this great
thing and they want to and to see it in
front of an audience usually for the
first time and a real audience as
opposed to you know family and friends
and film you know they're the guys who
are on the cruise
um so that's really good and do a q a
and get some feedback on the movie
that's what a film festival is really
good for for filmmakers
to get real third-party
um usually friendly by the way because
people go to film festivals are usually
friendly to independent films
so it's not as critical as if you
released your film in the theaters and
the critics you know took it apart
that's a little bit you know more
difficult but so a festival is good in
that way
my my sort of beef with festivals is two
things one is
they're curated really tightly and you
know i believe that festivals make most
of their money from
from submission fees i mean somewhere
between fifty and a hundred dollars for
most festivals to if you're gonna submit
a feature
i mean i've submitted to many many many
festivals so i know
and um you know you it's like college
admissions you know
like you you add it up you know like
sundance i think got
something like 30 000 submissions last
year for a hundred dollars each
so that's pretty good revenue just for
submissions
and uh i don't know if they even need to
screen any of the films
so remember only they're only going to
accept 300 films
so they're going to accept one percent
of what their submissions are and that's
not their fault everybody wants to get
in there right but it's expensive to
submit
especially when you're doing multiple
festivals and chances are you're not
going to get in
so i have a little bit of a beef with
that it's almost like
next time around like you know i don't
submit to festivals usually anymore
because
the the other because the other reason
is is when you do get in
um the screenings sometimes aren't very
well attended
the festivals are you know designed for
some of the bigger films and if you're
not a bigger film
unless you are generating the audience
and you know if you're in its city that
you know is you're not your
local city how are you going to generate
audience you don't know anybody you're
not going to spend a lot of money on
advertising it
the festival's supposed to do that so
you can go to a screening and have you
know 5 or 10 people there
and you're expecting you know 100 or 200
or 300 and this big q a and everything
like that and
you know it's usually often not the case
now you know sometimes it is
and you're excited and the other thing
is um
you don't get any revenue from your
screenings like you know say 300 people
come to your screening and they all paid
15 to come the festival gets it all
that's the deal
now sometimes a festival will pay for
you to attend
if you're you know a good-sized name
director or something like that or
whatever
but so that's nice but often they don't
anymore because they can't afford it
um so and the last thing is you know
i mean it's just about a celebration of
art and filmmaking
the festivals there's really no business
there it cost you to go cost you to
submit
um you have fun doing it and talking
other filmmakers and everything like
that but that's it i mean
you're not really gonna get distribution
the odd time maybe somebody will talk to
you but
about it or something like that um so
it's not what people say
and and chances of getting into the big
festivals is far and few between
so um the festivals serve a perfe a
purpose in terms of celebrating the art
of film
but i don't think they serve much of a
purpose in terms of generating revenue
yeah i think if you're going for that
reason i think that
it's you can weigh do i want to spend
the money do i want to spend the money
to travel there
yeah what about people who want the
laurels for their film website yeah
that's that's also nice that's fun
you know so it's nice to win an award i
mean you feel good your ego gets stroked
a little bit plus you know it does help
in marketing your film at least
it was recognized by somebody else um
it's not tremendously
important it doesn't hurt it doesn't
hurt but it's not i mean you see films
that have
15 laurels on them or whatever and it's
still a tough sell
yeah you know sometimes i say i used to
say this more and i shouldn't really say
it but
when i was a buyer like in distribution
and acquisition executive
um i would attend lots of festivals also
right because you know you want to be on
the you want to see the films before
anybody else sees them so you go to lots
of festivals watch lots of films
and sometimes i would walk out of a film
in a festival and
the audience you know would depending on
the type of audience it was
sometimes when a movie's really really
really popular in a festival
it almost means that it's not
commercially viable to go into the
mainstream
it's a festival film and it's designed
for that eclectic festival crowd
and sometimes it's the kiss of death
that it it's festival goers don't really
like commercially viable films
they don't like what they call these
bubblegum standard
you know predictable movies they like
something more eclectic and more
artistic
so when they love it it's almost like
it's not commercial enough to go
into regular distribution not always
but you know a lot of acquisition people
know
that there is a difference between a
very successful festival film and a very
successful commercial film
like most real big hollywood blockbuster
movies
um they go to festivals because that's
because there's the stars and everybody
wants to see the stars and and they use
them as a as a launch pad
but i mean they're not artistic and
eclectic enough
for the film festival crowd the only
reason they go there is because they use
them as
you know this publicity stunt but um a
lot of them
wouldn't even bother with the festival
crowd because um it's the commercial
crowd it's the ticket buying crowd that
they really care about
that's fascinating and are those those
aren't really cinephiles
those are more people that are going
after or before dinner
well look the the biggest movies are you
know are the action
sci-fi superhero would you ever would a
superhero movie ever go to a festival
i mean other than a superhero festival
you know there are some superhero
festivals
you know comic-con has a film you know
okay like
would would a superhero movie ever show
at sundance
hopefully not because that would be you
know challenge the integrity of the
sundance film festival
why would a superhero there's no
artistic merit but there's a lot of
commercial merit to it tons of it
and that's going to be the number one
blockbuster movie of the season
but yet they would never stick it into
festivals because
it's the wrong message right unless it
was a very eclectic
superhero but if it was it likely
wouldn't be successful
commercially that's true because the
people who go to those movies aren't the
people who go to festivals
there are some crossovers i happen to be
one of them
but most people are either commercial
you know moviegoers for mainstream
kind of thoughtless you know action
stuff or they're very eclectic
and want a little more depth and art and
you know
thought